want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know you've got so much more inside
you you've got michael jordan level
genius at something so today let's live
your best believe life and get some
incredible motivation from the one and
only jay shetty enjoy
you can't plan your life 30 years ahead
you don't need to and i think that's a
pressure that we put on ourselves like
oh my god what am i doing what am i
going to be doing when i'm 50 and it's
like well actually hopefully you'll be
doing something that surprises you
and why not just let your life surprise
you constantly
why make it out like life is like linear
perfect journey we're like at 30. i'm
going to do this and i'm 40. i'm going
to do this and at 50 and it's like well
life probably is not going to go like
that and that picture that you have
rolling
because it won't fit in with what you're
experiencing that gap is the pressure
that you feel in your life
the reason i'm saying don't put purpose
on a pedestal
is because then purpose becomes this
heavy weight that you're carrying
and you're now like
judging yourself that you don't know it
and if you instead make your goal to
learn about purpose learn about meaning
explore yourself experiment grow now it
becomes like
oh i'm just experimenting i'm just
learning about myself
if you don't really have an interest
it's going to be really hard and when it
comes to our soft skills we go oh i'm a
good communicator i'm just going to
stick to that forget vulnerability or
i'm a really good talker forget
listening
and that kind of all comes in together
and i think the point is that if we're
always learning and figuring out a way
to serve in whatever situation we're in
that's that's the best route for success
because that's something that no one can
take away from you we like stress out
about not being motivated we stress out
about not finding purpose but guess what
just like you've got to eat and shower
you have to find purpose in every day
i think that we have to get as intimate
with our dark side as possible and i
feel like when you don't get that
intimacy you don't really understand it
i look back and i think why did i do
that and it's just always been my desire
to experiment always been my desire to
learn always been my desire to be
curious and find out more about myself
the first is to approach any situation
with compassion and empathy the other
thing is to recognize that sometimes
when we go through pain
it makes us pay attention
like when we go through pain it makes us
pay attention when things are going
great we often get complacent
we stop worrying we get lazy we don't
worry about anything we're just relaxing
and as soon as you feel pain
[Music]
pain is a way of your body of society of
the economy to force you to pay
attention so if you're being lazy and
not eating right your body reacts badly
to tell you to stop doing that so any
pain that happens in your life first of
all is saving you from more pain
and so for me that's the shift that we
have to go through and that all comes
from us
deeply looking into our minds and going
where are these blocks turning up from
where are they coming from what are
their roots and then how can i replace
them with
the the right conversation the right
dialogue internally when it comes to
your hard skills focus on your strengths
when it comes to your soft skills focus
on your weaknesses if you do those two
things your life will change
dramatically because if you're good at
something you'll become exceptional at
it life is challenging it's full of ups
and downs we think i wish things could
just be still
i wish things would stop changing
i wish my problems would go away
we want a life that's steady with a path
that's flat
yet as deborah evans once said
life is like an ekg
without the ups and downs
you're not living
because this is what a flat line looks
like
and this is what a lifeline looks like
when we feel those highest highs those
extreme peaks
we're ecstatic to be on the summit
then when we're in the lowest lows those
deep values we're ready to submit and so
we try and play it safe and avoid all
risks
but when we seek security and prioritize
passiveness we don't realize that a flat
lifeline
means we're dead
if we're always trying to live our lives
at sea level then we'll never see what
life is truly about
that what we judge as good and bad
are in fact deeply connected
how could we ever experience how
wonderful happiness is
if we never felt sadness
how could we taste the triumph of
success
if we never failed how could we know the
comfort of gratitude
if we never experienced loss
somehow we got the idea that being
successful and moving forward in life
means we're constantly moving up
but have you ever read a book watched a
movie or seen a case study like that
they don't exist every story worth
telling has peaks and valleys successes
and setbacks
our brains are wired for novelty when
something's new whether it's a fantastic
surprise or a huge challenge our brains
light up we thrive on learning and our
opportunities to grow yet our brains
also easily become accustomed to
patterns making it harder for us to
change
dramatic disruptions help us break these
patterns and invite us to see and
experience the world in a whole new way
and as it turns out we're designed for
change all the way down to ourselves
your body is constantly being reinvented
replacing most of itself every seven to
fifteen years even down to our bones
the universe is constantly shifting and
we are part of that when we try and
resist change it goes against our very
nature
in the journey of life we experience
pleasure and pain there'll be sunshine
and rain there will be loss in gain but
we must learn to keep moving forward
again and again so if you open your eyes
this morning
if you were healthy enough to move about
to maybe get yourself some food
if you were able to go to a refrigerator
and find that it was full and stocked
if you were able to put on some clothes
and if you had a roof over your head
just remember how grateful you can be
for all those things we consider to be
basic
but for others
they don't even have access to
we can't stop life's ups and downs but
we can change how we experience them
we can learn to go with life's flow
because as helen keller once said
life is either a daring adventure
or nothing at all harvard did a recent
study on three 000
leaders managers individuals working
inside organizations
and they looked at the top performing
ones and they wondered and asked
what was the number one skill they had
and it came down to this one word
associating the ability
to connect dots
where people usually see differences
the ability to find parallels and
similarities and synergies where other
people
only see divide and disconnection we
live in these echo chambers inside our
organizations we get lost around the
same group of three to four people we
get lost in the same many groups of
people and we don't expand our minds
beyond that people with broader networks
people who had people in their lives
that were very different from the other
people were actually able to provide
more creative more productive more
effective ideas and solutions in the
company because they were able to look
at things from multiple angles different
perspectives how can we start to
recognize
that when we win
and someone else wins when we win
together when we're able to help and
serve and support each other together
so much more can happen there's a
wonderful verse in the manusmithi which
i talk about think like a monk it's a
monk book and in the verse it says when
you protect your purpose
your purpose protects you
now i wanna i wanna unpack that what i
mean by that is
your purpose is like a rare jewel
and a rare gemstone
and imagine you were walking around with
the most expensive diamond or jewel in
the world how would you protect it you
want to just like you would just wait
without you yeah you wouldn't just wear
it on your chest like this like a baby
holding it yeah putting a pillow around
a blanket you do like yeah protect it
you'd protect it and so your purpose is
like that and guess what people are
going to tell you every day
that that jewel is not worth anything
they're going to tell you that that
jewel is actually
valueless it doesn't have any
impact on your life they're going to try
and take away that value they're going
to tell you that there's another jewel
out there that you need to have more
value
and what ends up happening is you don't
i love the word look at the wording
protect your purpose you have to protect
it so what happens is your success grows
you get more opportunities more ideas
more things coming your way temptations
but they can all take you away from your
purpose
distractions
and to me i'm repeating this for myself
because i'm like i just want to stick to
what i was born to do and i'm so
grateful that i get to do it i'm so
happy i get to do it and i want to keep
protecting it i don't want to get lost
in the waves you know you don't want to
just get chucked in the waves of the
ocean and just get lost and just not
know where you're going so for me when
you protect your purpose your purpose
protects you so that's been your biggest
lesson that's my biggest lesson why do
you feel like your purpose has been
maybe distracted i don't think it has
but i'm saying it so it doesn't
remind you yeah i'm reminding myself
like i'm preaching to myself right now
especially being in hollywood and the
temptation of all these opportunities
out here totally and i think for me it's
a bigger lesson also because it gives me
more faith so i always encourage and
this is actually actually this is why
it's my biggest lesson i encourage so
many people that i coach so many people
i mentor obviously everyone in my
community and audience and everything to
go and follow that go and live that
purpose and i see time and time again
that when i see people
trying to live their purpose they are
protected that it things work when
you're playing in your dharma and your
purpose things work things move you feel
momentum they happen and i'm not saying
they happen without effort but they
happen they move whereas when you're not
you just constantly feel like you're
grinding up against
you know a war i never believed i was an
entrepreneur and i never thought i
wanted to be one because in my heart of
hearts i'm an artist first in my heart
of hearts i'm a content creator i'm a
thinker i'm a visionary i'm an artist
that's why i really identify with being
but what i realized very quickly was
if you just wanted to be that and you
were gonna wait to find people to spot
your talent teach you everything about
business and make every decision for you
it was never going to happen and i think
a lot of artists are waiting to be found
and discovered and managed and molded
and that their agent's going to change
their life and i'm like that doesn't
work like that you have to do the work
yourself you have to do the work
yourself yeah and so it's very well said
by the way for someone that actually is
in the position helping people and doing
that a lot of people think they don't
have to do the work but you 100 have to
do the work yourself yeah and i just
meet so many people and i love my
manager i love my agents i've got a
great team of people around me but
they
are able to do more for me when i do
more for myself so well said and and i
find that so many people and me included
at one point i was waiting i thought
someone's gonna find me and then they're
gonna like change my career and change
my life and guess what that didn't
happen yeah and i realized that i had to
invent and i had to create and i had to
push so becoming an entrepreneur for me
was learning
because i was like i don't want to be
left behind and i don't want to be the
person that doesn't reach my potential
which means i'm going to have to learn
skills i never thought now funny story
when i was 16 and i was hanging out in
the wrong circles i used to import
jackets from china and sell them at
school and all of this kind of stuff so
i was like i had a hustler i had i had
that in me but i forgot that and this is
what happens that when you go to school
and university and family you forget
who what your natural dial was so for me
i started reading books i started
spending time with people who were
successful in the area i wanted to learn
i went and shadowed people i got
mentored by people did you intern at all
i didn't intern afterwards but i
interned a lot when i was uh
at college and university but then since
then like in the last few years i think
it's mainly been picking up the phone to
people getting to know people and this
is what i've realized if you're putting
out content
and people can see you they're more
likely to pick up the phone and connect
and i had this experience where i went
out to someone and they didn't realize i
recognized them so i got invited on this
podcast in new york
and it was an influencer from linkedin
and he didn't know i knew him because he
he found me a different way and booked
me through someone else but when he met
me i was like dude i know you i see your
content on linkedin
and and he me you know he was shocked
that i even knew he was but i was like
i've seen you i see how you tell stories
and i think you're going to grow and
become an incredible linkedin thinker
one day
but i see it now and i'm like i was more
likely whereas if that was someone i'd
never heard of i probably wouldn't have
gone on yeah yeah and so i feel like
when you're putting out content when
you're creating and sharing what your
perspective is you're more likely to
attract the right energy around you
rather than when you're waiting for
someone to just discover you what was
the thing that made you choose to
actually commit on such a deeper level
i think it was that when i was doing the
two lives i got to see what life looked
like at both ends yeah so i got to see
what like a cool life working in the
city wearing a posh suit to work every
day driving a fast car
you know
having a beautiful girlfriend at the
time like all that kind of stuff i got
to see what that felt like and then i
got to see what it felt like living as a
monk in india and it's so weird to say
it and this is why i believe that more
people should have what i call immersive
experiences like when you think you want
to be an entrepreneur that's different
go and work with an entrepreneur for a
week and then think if you like the
process yeah not the result right like
don't look at the chains in the car and
the home
look at whether you like what time that
person wakes up like we're in the gym
every week together yep right at the
same time every week we're committed
we're committed and i'm sure you'll hear
today we're in your space in your studio
like you're committed and i think
because i'd done that for four years
actually making the decision was easy
because i already knew what i was
getting myself into it's kind of like
dating versus marriage it's like if
you've never dated you don't know you
want to spend the rest of your life with
someone yeah and so i had dated for the
last four years with both these lives
and then i was like okay i prefer this
one that's literally it now i'm not
telling you to cheat on people and date
two people at a time the analogy applies
to this but the point being that if you
go and experience life decision making
becomes easy if you're trying to do it
all of the theory in your head of like
crap do i become a monk or do i become a
finance person like you'd never figure
that out yeah but when you go live it
and you're like
i felt happier doing that yeah and
that's what it was i felt happier i felt
i was going to have a bigger impact on
the world because we were not just
meditating all day we were building food
distribution programs charity
philanthropy programs like we were doing
work in the world to help people yeah
and that's where i got most activated
like i'll tell you what actually this is
it this is the true answer the reason
why i decided to become monk was i
wanted to study everything about
philosophy and life and i wanted to be
able to live it for real and so i was
addicted to learning about wisdom yeah
and the second thing was i was like i
want to use my life to have a meaning
and impact in the world and at that
point in time i'd not seen people do
that through business
i'd not seen people do it through
entrepreneurship and success yeah i'd
only seen people do it in that way and
so now that's different i believe you
can have an impact through business etc
yeah but at that time i'd not seen that
yeah how many of you get to the
afternoon and start to feel
tired lethargic fatigued you want to
take a nap but then you look at your
to-do list and you realize you still
have 77 things left to do the first and
easiest thing we can do is
hydrate i know it doesn't sound like
rocket science and it isn't one of those
clever hacks but it can make a huge
difference alkaline water specifically
has a much bigger impact on your energy
levels as well so i try to stick to that
chances are when you're feeling tired
you're going to want to reach for
something with fats and carbs i know
when i get tired i want to reach for
some chocolate some donuts maybe a bagel
but that's not really what your body
needs what you need is a high protein
snack and so you want to turn towards
something like fruits nuts seeds
anything that you actually may not want
at that moment you may not want to taste
it but i promise you you'll feel much
better for it now if you're a tea lover
you already know the benefits of a hot
cup of tea but if you're not i want to
let you know that certain teas have
herbs and adaptogens that help your body
get back up to balance so if you're
feeling stressed they'll de-stress you
if you're feeling anxiety they can lower
that down and on top of that the art of
taking a cup of tea
inhaling the scent
feeling it in your body
and then looking at the color gives you
that sense of pores that you need in the
day and re-energizes you immediately
i recently did a test to check my
vitamins and i realized that i was
really deficient in vitamin d the doctor
explained to me that because of the
color of my skin no matter how much time
i spend in the sun i need to be taking
vitamin d now she was actually shocked
that i could even get out of bed that's
how much vitamin d is connected to our
energy levels so if you're starting to
feel fatigued a bit earlier than usual
get a vitamin d check and start taking
some vitamin d learn from the past but
don't live there this is actually a
picture of don schuler a famous nfl
coach if you like nfl one of the most
well respected nfl coaches and he had
this great theory well not theory
practice
he gave his all his players
24 hours only to celebrate a success
or cry over a loss he said you've got 24
hours to feel your emotions 24 hours to
success be successful champion it have a
celebration whatever you want to do
you've only got 24 hours make the most
of that 24 hours and if you're gonna cry
i'm giving you 24 hours after that we
forget about it and the reason why i
love this statement is this statement
learned from the past but don't live
there is usually used as saying our past
is negative
but i want to apply it to the positive
as well often we sit back and with
nostalgia reflect on our best memories
right and this nostalgic thing makes us
still live in the past and it doesn't
necessarily let us build for the future
one of my favorite examples of it is
when steve jobs went back to apple
he went in there and the first thing he
did is that he crushed the museum that
they built of all the history apple had
because he said he didn't want to be
working for a company that was built on
just all of this past recognition and
success he wanted to be building a
company of the future he got rid of this
big museum they had in the entrance of
apple when he went back after
losing his job the first time
and so this is what i'm talking about
let's not live in the past right
let's learn from the past but not live
there and they did some great studies
with the armies they did with the u.s
army and then they did this with the
israel defense forces and i'm sure you
do this at work so they did after action
reviews but i'd love for you to do this
in your own life so they found that when
they had two groups of soldiers one
group of soldiers reflected on only the
failures of all of their actions and the
other group reflected on the failures
and their successes
they found after doing this for a
certain amount of time they found that
the soldiers that focused on both the
failures and successes not only
performed better in future tasks they
were betterly mentally situated to
actually inspire and empower their
colleagues as well
so when you're reflecting don't just
learn from the past by learning from the
failures learn from the successes as
well build them into that because we
start developing a story and a pattern
for life
we
will continue to create the life that we
currently have with the current set of
thoughts wisdom beliefs and ideas that
we have and if we're happy on that path
if you could fast forward your life in
10 20 30 years time and you'd be
satisfied with getting the life that you
have right now
then that's great
but if like the majority of people that
i know and that i speak to and that i
connect with online the majority of us
would look and go no i really want to
change life i want to be with my kids
but i want to change how i am with them
i want to be at work but i want to be
more present at work i want to improve
the quality of my life
then i'd say that it's so important that
we learn and open up our minds to
alternative thoughts i'll give you an
example there's this great study that
mit did
on people's minds openness and their
ability to be creative and innovative
and they looked at two types of people
one person was surrounded by people who
all knew the same people right kind of
like our normal lives and the other
person was surrounded by lots of people
who didn't know each other
and they did the study around who is
more creative more innovative and has a
bigger impact in the workplace
in their professional life and then a
little bit into their personal life as
well
and what they found was that those
people who knew people who knew each
other who knew them back
lived in what was known as echo chambers
they were rarely exposed to ideas that
improved their way of living or their
professional performance but people who
are exposed to ideas that had no
connection with other people in their
life were able to be more creative have
better ideas have more purpose have more
meaning in life so often we've become
closed in our little spaces around what
we hear what we know about
and we're not exposed to this new sense
of ideas and that's what i would
encourage is just approach it with a
tiny bit of curiosity that's all you
need the next step is creating
accountability
the reason why we procrastinate is
because we're left to our own devices if
i don't feel like doing it i don't have
to do it i can procrastinate i can
overthink i can get distracted
when i really want to work on something
i find an accountability partner i've
had to do it with my health for a long
long time i don't enjoy working out
you've heard me say that before but i
want to be fit i want to be healthy and
i want to be alert and i know that
exercise is a big part of making that
possible i found an accountability
partner in my tennis coach she always
shows up she always shows up on time and
she'll make sure i get there if i get
one of those excuses like oh i'm feeling
tired today or i'm a bit sore today
she'll make sure that i'm there playing
tennis no matter what knowing that
someone else is already out there when
it's cold when it's raining when it's
hot when they're tired allows you to
push yourself out of your comfort zone
when you really need to work on
something and improve something you
often have to do it when you don't feel
like doing it when you don't feel like
doing something it doesn't mean you
shouldn't do it because that's when you
have to connect with the feeling after
we get so obsessed about how we feel
before something when the feeling after
is that much more important before you
eat healthy food you might not be
attracted to it after you eat healthy
food you feel good about yourself but if
you see that burger you see those fries
or you see that chocolate fudge cake it
feels good before but then afterwards
you usually regret it words that we
should use
more of in our life
are words that
give us
the right feeling we want to feel so
i'll give an example
instead of saying now i work super hard
i do get tired
and i do get exhausted
sometimes i'm very aware of it and i'm
cautious of it
and i realized that for a long time i
just kept repeating i'm tired i'm
exhausted i'm tired i'm exhausted and
i'd say to my wife i'd say to my team
overwhelmed
yeah and i still do it sometimes so it's
not that i'm perfect but you make me
aware of it and i say that i started to
realize that okay it didn't make me feel
better by saying it and actually what i
was trying to do was get validation from
someone else to be like i know how hard
you work and you're amazing and blah
blah blah and so you know you're really
doing it for a reaction and then i
started to realize well
i am tired but why don't i just say
i'm going to make some time to nap today
uh i need to i need to find some time
today to rest
i need to make sure that i uh you know
get some time to myself today like when
you flip it not by just saying oh i feel
amazing because i don't feel amazing
again you don't lie to yourself but
you're trying to create words
that help you actually get what you need
so me saying i'm tired
really what i need to be saying is i
need to get some more rest today i
better sleep early and then you go all
right you know to rather you know what i
think i'm gonna sleep early tonight
that's that's perfect because now i'll
sleep early and i'll get the rest and i
won't be tired hey riley i'm so tired it
just creates this negative pattern of
complaining and whining and and creating
that you know
we know that we have around 60 to 80 000
thoughts per day the most incredible
thing is these thoughts are cycling
they're not only repetitive but they're
also negative
i realize that knowing which of the most
repetitive and negative thoughts allows
you to spot their trigger do you
experience this when you're on social
media do you experience this when you're
watching a particular show or you're
around certain people what we want to do
is find that trigger
trace that trigger back to its root and
reduce that activity in our life
often what we think is causing us
anxiety is different from the root of
where it started it was wayne dyer who
said when we change the way we look at
things the things we look at change
let's look at our thoughts differently
stop thinking that you are your thoughts
and that your thoughts are all you are
recognizing that we're so much more
beyond our thoughts allows us to
disconnect and distance from them and
then upgrade them towards healthier
thoughts
don't make procrastination the enemy we
think procrastination is bad it's
useless it's not going to help us it
shows that we're fearful or insecure
but procrastination can often be the
greatest space for creativity
allowing yourself to doodle allowing
yourself to free think to free write to
freestyle is so important now i can't
draw the best i'm not the best sketcher
but i love putting pen to paper and just
allowing my mind to flow through my hand
allowing myself to discover new ideas
new shapes new thoughts new names some
of my best inventions and ideas have
come from just allowing myself to
procrastinate and to overthink sunny
brown in her book called the doodle
revolution talks about how some of the
greatest minds in the world doodled and
allowed themselves to discover new ideas
insanity is doing the same thing over
and over again expecting a different
result
right so if you find in your life when
you reflect about this question that
you're going through the same challenges
regularly
remember a challenge will never go away
until you learn what you're meant to
learn from it so if you're seeing the
same challenge coming up again and again
in your personal lives realize that it's
trying to teach you something as soon as
you extrapolate that lesson you'll get
on to the next challenge right they
don't go away but you go up a level you
go up to the next level so notice that
as well remember insanity is doing the
same thing over and over again expecting
a different result one of my first
things in failure
is
don't take it more personally than it
actually is and i'll give an example of
that when i was applying to
40 companies that all rejected me before
an interview yeah
all i was getting was an automated
response
saying your application will not go any
further
i can't take that personally because
they didn't meet me in person they
didn't have a
interaction with me they just saw my
name they saw i've been a monk for three
years
that resume is useless i mean what's
your transferable skills like sitting in
silence and students surprise surprise
no one wants to hire a monk and so they
rejected you but that's not personal
because they didn't meet me in person
what if they had me right so that's the
first thing the first step is don't take
all
failure i'll give an example me and you
we reach out to countless guests to be
on our podcast we say no all the time
you're saying all the time but if i
don't hear a no from the guest directly
that's not a no like someone's team can
say no someone's assistant can say no
someone's pr team can say no but until
they say no personally
it's not a no okay but when they do say
no then that's a note yeah so then let's
move on how do you deal with that type
of failure yes so if i deal with a
failure where someone meets me in person
and gets the no no jay you're horrible
you suck like i don't want to deal with
a monk ever in my life yeah i would
never go on your show i'm never
listening to you never yeah then how do
you deal with that type so i've heard
you say this i've said it a couple of
times and i'm sure it's been repeated a
bunch of times around how i genuinely
believe failure has feedback
and and so for me it's like failure has
the ability
to actually tell you what you need to
improve now not to improve to get their
attention
improving to get the actions that you
want to take yeah the results you want
the results you want and don't make that
result about the person who said no
don't try use failure as a way to prove
someone else wrong because what happens
when we prove others wrong when you
prove others wrong you end up trying to
get validation and approval for them and
now if they're not impressed when you're
right you lose again so you end up
losing twice and you spend all this time
and energy years maybe to prove
something wrong i've been there many
times and then you're like i felt good
for a moment yeah and then i feel empty
again totally and and so that's the
thing about failure in the second half
is you have to see failure as an
improvement if if i'm completely honest
everyone who rejected me in my life up
until now
has
made me more hungry taught me so much
more about myself and made me up my game
yeah and i think if failure doesn't make
you up your game it's the same as losing
in a sport
right when you fail and you've lost
games and you've won games on the big
stages you didn't have the skills you
didn't have the teamwork you guys
weren't hungry enough you would never
enjoy enough there's something you were
missing yeah so you go review the game
film you check the stats you see what
could have done better and you try to
improve that for the next game yeah i
think a lot of people can do that in
life but we're so afraid to like go on
the next game of life like i got
rejected once and it hurts so bad yeah
how do people learn to overcome that
pain of rejection yeah yeah keep going
yeah you know in sports luckily there's
a season which like you might have 30
basketball games after you lose the
first two you don't say i'm just going
to give up the rest of the season yeah
you keep playing yes but in life a lot
of people stop playing yeah why yeah i
think that's great mental training too i
think sports is great mental training
because you have to show up to the next
game even if you're lost and you don't
feel bad exactly that you don't feel
good sorry and and one of the things
before i dive into that question one of
the things that you reminded me of was
that the last dance documentary so
there's that season
that michael jordan everyone is
agreement in an agreement that he is one
of the best players
to be playing and they keep losing they
didn't make a fight they didn't make the
finals they lost
and then they realized they need to get
the team and they need to find i think
they bring in dennis rodman and then
start bringing in all these other
players that strengthen whereas if they
would have just said oh we got the best
player in the world we just keep doing
this
i'm not sure they would have got there
right but the coach phil jackson and the
team they had to adapt and so
you're saying why do we feel that pain
in rejection and how do we deal with
that
i think we feel that pain because we
look at a failure
right we look at it as a complete
definition of us right we're looking at
as as there's that famous statement of
like you know failure is an event not a
person right and i don't know who said
it but it's one of those statements that
that really clicks like failure is uh an
event not a person whereas we start
thinking we are the failure like we say
i am a failure
if you had 100 hours to invest in your
self-development in what you were good
at what you were average at and what you
were bad at how would you split that
time when this question was asked to 200
of the most healthy wealthy wise people
in the world what they found is that
their percentages were 100
or 80 10 10 and the reason for this was
very simple when we focus on things
we're naturally good at
and we invested them
we become exceptional at them
when we focus on things that we're
average at
we may get good at them and when we
focus on things we're naturally bad at
we may become average at them the hard
skills that we have
the actual hard tangible skills that we
have we should focus on our strengths
but when it comes to our qualities our
emotional intelligence
we should focus on our weaknesses so if
you have a challenge with something like
listening
you don't go oh yeah jay told me not to
focus on my weaknesses so i'm not going
to bother getting better at my listening
right listening is a
soft skill if you have a weakness in a
soft skill you want to give that your
energy
but if you have a strength and a hard
skill you want to give that your energy
and focus and usually we do it the other
way around if we're bad listeners we're
good at something else we let it roll we
say oh that's okay that's not a big deal
but when it comes to things like empathy
emotional intelligence vulnerability
listening communication connection these
are things that we can improve in
and when it comes to our natural
strengths
our skills are hard skills we can play
to those as well when we play to our
strengths when we understand our role
and our offering and we recognize that
actually that person has their offering
we recognize it's not that we disagree
with each other it's not that person's
trying to take me down it's just that we
speak different languages we generally
talk to people like they're exactly the
same
and people generally talk to us like
we're exactly the same we usually expect
that people will respond to things in
the same way as we will we just have
this lens until we start recognizing
that there are different wirings for
different people so they all respond to
different things and there's a beautiful
statement that's often attributed to
albert einstein where he said that
everyone's a genius
but if you judge a fish by its ability
to climb a tree it will spend its whole
life believing that it's stupid
and so many of us in our own life are
either trying to be something or we're
connecting with people differently all
of us can mindfully
approach any conversation in the
workplace with a partner potentially
even with a patient or wherever it is
understanding that person's language the
point being that
everyone was trying to achieve the same
goal and i want you to do that i want
you to give yourself the benefit of the
doubt and the people around you that
everyone is trying to work towards the
same goal
if we can just learn to speak each
other's language
then we'll be able to improve our
communication where do our challenges
arise and our challenges arise by how we
see ourselves
and what i believe wrong is referring to
is there's this quote that i begin my
book with and that i've shared in
interviews for the last few years and
it's from a writer named charles
houghton cooley who wrote this in the
1900s and what he said is that
sorry i think it's in the 1800s at the
end of the 1800s towards the 1900s and
he said and bear with me and you've got
to really listen closely to this so what
he said that the challenge today is
i'm not what i think i am
i'm not what you think i am
i am what i think you think i am
now just let that blow your mind for a
moment i will explain it i promise i'm
not what i think i am i'm not what you
think i am i am what i think you think i
am which means
we live in a perception of a perception
of ourselves so i'll break it down if i
think
rangan thinks i'm smart
i'll say i feel smart but if i think
rangan thinks i'm not smart then i'll
say i'm not smart
and so the challenge is that we're
basing how we feel about ourselves on
what we think someone thinks of us and
and the greatest challenge with that is
how do you have any idea
if what you think someone thinks about
you is even true and whether that's even
the best place to start so that's where
our identity struggles we start pursuing
things in life because we think other
people value them it's almost like let's
think of the most playground version of
this
if i remember wearing high-tech shoes
from bhs to the playground right i
remember my mom because my parents
didn't buy me nike uh trainers uh or
adidas trainers which i always wanted
you know we didn't come from that
background i couldn't i couldn't afford
them and my parents didn't want me to
have them so i'd walk in with my high
tech
trainers from bhs they were about ten
quid or whatever they were
and and and you know to me
it didn't make a difference i didn't
really know at that time whether
high-tech was good or bad they were just
trainers that my parents bought me now
everyone the cool kid at school had the
latest nike trainers
all of a sudden i start thinking that
he's now surrounded by everyone
everyone's talking about his trainers
everyone's giving him adoration
everyone's giving him respect everyone's
talking about his trainers
so now i think that if i want to have
that same experience and love from
people that i need to get that
not realizing that i may be able to get
deeper love from people
by being kind and compassionate that i
may actually be able to build a real
relationship with people if i'm loving
and and considerate and empathetic and
it's so crazy how your life can become
about pursuing something and that's why
jim carrey puts it best and i'm
paraphrasing he says you know everyone
in the world should achieve everything
they've ever wanted and accomplish
everything they've ever pursued
just to realize that it's not the point
now that doesn't mean the monk mindset
is not about not pursuing your goals
it's actually about pursuing your truest
goals your truest self and your most
authentic aligned goals so it's not
about not having goals it's about making
sure that your goals are actually yours
you can't be logical and creative at the
same time your brain and mind is using
different faculties and different
abilities to do different types of tasks
imagine you're in meetings all day about
numbers and data and analytics and all
of a sudden you're asked to do something
creative maybe write a speech or give a
presentation it can be really really
difficult to switch from one side of
your brain to the other side in a matter
of seconds with very little organizing
and planning we're literally going like
a pendulum swinging from one task to
another which is requiring different
parts of our brain and the abilities
that we have the way i solve this is
that i start every day by first writing
down my to-do list i look at all the
activities that i have to do now in the
examples i give in this video i've
simplified my task to make it easier but
know that i do this with a lot more
detail you want to draw a line down the
middle of the page on one side of it
write logical and on the other side of
it write creative you now want to plot
and mark where these tasks on your to-do
list fit either in the logical category
or in the creative category the question
you're asking yourself is is this task
largely structured
focused does it have certain boundaries
is it quite a logical step-by-step
process
or is this creative is it more of a
brainstorm is it somewhere where you
need to feel free and expressive after
you've divided these tasks you now want
to write down the time estimate that
that specific task is going to take what
ends up happening is you start to plot
your week by saying monday is going to
be creative tuesdays are logical
wednesdays are logical thursdays are
creative and fridays are creative
or you may also divide your day up into
logical mornings and creative afternoons
or creative mornings and logical
afternoons this division this time
blocking allows you to get really
immersed into the activity really focus
and be more productive one of my
favorite ways to start
is looking
at what we value
and values are a very intangible word
and so there's a very easy way to figure
out what you value there's two things
you have to look at
you look at how you spend your money the
most painful thing you can possibly do
go through your bank statement and look
at where your money is being spent that
is what you value
the other thing that we spend just like
we spend money
is how we spend our time
those are the two most perfect ways to
see what you currently value your value
isn't what's in your head isn't what's
in your heart it isn't what's in your
mind it's how you spend your money and
how you spend your time and so just to
give you an overview and i share this in
the book that research was done on how
we spend our time
and the research showed that we spent 33
years in bed
right 33 years of our life in bed and
seven years of that is spent trying to
sleep not even sleeping right we spend
one year and four months exercising
across our whole lives these are by the
way we spend more than three years on
vacation
and we spend a bunch of days trying to
get ready and we spend a bunch of time
you know standing in lines and queues
and so much of our time just gets spent
so the question we have to ask ourselves
is
where am i currently spending my time
and where do i want to spend it now
studies also show
that people everyone has to go to work
so this isn't about what you do for work
people who had more meaningful
purposeful lives and while healthier
wealthier and wise
invest their time in education over
entertainment
and wrong and your
your audience is lucky because they get
education and entertainment in one place
but but that's the goal right like
that's the goal that you're creating an
opportunity for people to find education
the the smartest the wealthiest the most
healthiest the wisest people in the
world reading books watching
documentaries taking courses listening
to podcasts learning to better
themselves
and so that's the first place to start
the second place when we look at that
value audit
is i want you to write down three things
that you're currently pursuing in life
it might be a promotion it might be a
new home whatever it is whatever it is
that you are currently pursuing
and then i want you to ask this question
is that your desire and your dream
or is it coming from something outside
of you is it coming from a pressure of a
family member is it coming from an
expectation because your friend just
bought something where is that desire
truly coming from
and the third and final question you
want to ask yourself is do i still want
to pursue that or do i want to change
how i pursue it
or do i not want to pursue it at all and
if you go through that three-step
questioning process you'll get to the
truth of what you truly want to pursue
and stop yourselves from building a sand
castle which the waves of time will
eventually wash away
and so that's what we get lost doing we
get lost building castles that we don't
even want to live in here's a way that
you can actually get more out of the
same time i learned this from my good
friend ariana huffington who speaks
about habit stacking now we all have
habits in our life that we do every
single day without even thinking about
it we're driving around town we're
cooking every single day we may be on a
walk these are great times to immerse in
those activities for sure when you're
driving to be fully present if you're
going on a hike to be really there
within nature and if you're cooking to
be really present with the scents the
sounds and and all of the different
colors that may be there
but
if you're someone who can do some of
those things pretty comfortably you can
also add a stack of a habit so for
example you may be someone who listens
to an audiobook while driving you may be
someone that listens to a podcast while
cooking or while you're on a hike or
walking the dog it's okay to have it
stack in those scenarios to get more out
of the same amount of time i wrote about
this in my book
it's called location has energy time has
memory when you do something in the same
place every day at the same time every
day that space builds an energy and that
time builds a memory what does that mean
when you've done something in one place
like meditated in the same place for a
considerable amount of time that space
takes on a meditative energy and
frequency it becomes easier to do that
activity in that place and similarly
when you do something at the same time
every day that time has a memory your
body your mind remember that and
therefore it becomes easier to do
divide your home even in corners i
remember when my wife and i lived in a
500 square foot apartment and literally
every corner of that room was divided
into a meditation corner a social corner
a work corner and an eating corner even
that differentiation allowed you to keep
the energy of that space sacred and
appropriate for what you want to do the
challenge today is we eat when we're
meant to sleep
we sleep where we're meant to work and
we work where we're meant to eat so
we've confused the energy of our
environment that's why we're sitting in
bed and can't sleep because we do so
many different activities there
remove that energy from the bedroom
place it where it needs to be and allow
yourself to see how you use your time
more effectively whenever you give out
any energy love
hate
anger
kindness
you will always get it back
one way or another
love is like a circle
whatever love you give out
it always comes back to you
i was just showing
sally a facebook memory backstage
seven years ago
i love facebook reminders
it showed me that i was speaking to this
little group of students
about seven mistakes people make in
their twenties
and it was a memory of a talk that i was
giving six and seven years ago i
released my first video five years ago
so six and seven years ago most people
didn't know who i was and what i was
doing had an event in london
called conscious living it was on a
friday night in the city
and five to ten people would show up
every week that's it five to ten people
and i remember loving it and i remember
feeling so happy and so grateful that
five to ten people showed up and i feel
the same way about the first five to ten
people that followed me and commented on
my videos and i feel the same way about
the first five to ten people when i
finally got to meet them and i found
that
if you can love
one person if you can deeply feel
grateful for one person
then
thousands hundreds of thousands millions
will come from that but if you struggle
to be
present and connected to that one person
it's really hard
to be trusted by the universe with more
what is it that success looks like for
you and don't make it about a number
don't make it about an account of views
don't make it about a follower don't
make it about the size of home because
those things
are great for success
but they're not great for happiness
my measure of success is
can i wake up and do something i love
every day i think we've come to a place
where we feel that
freedom
and the freedom of unlimited choice
is power
and we've all realized and the science
and the studies all show this that the
more choice we have the worst mistakes
we make and we make poorer decisions
based on this complete limitless choice
and i found that actually when you
stripped away some of that choice
your ability to make decisions grew my
meditation teacher said to me even in a
shallow dive you get wet so still do it
beautiful
i love it
the first step
is learning
to appreciate where you are
because if we can't appreciate where we
are
we will never appreciate where we get to
and i often say to people like you're
exactly where you need to be
and we're scared of accepting that
because you're like well i don't like
being here but that's because we don't
see it as part of our story and then the
third part of it truly
is that i've seen the most powerful
dreams
be linked to service
and impact
and so when your dream expands into
having a service element you get the
opportunity to work harder than you've
ever dreamed of you're able to learn
things that you never believed you could
because we're so phenomenal at extending
ourselves
beyond what we know for people that we
love and people we want to serve you
want to make sure that in any habit
change there is some reward and a reward
is making sure you recognize what
amazing growth you're making that you're
taking a moment to see look how far i've
come because our mind again tricks us
and always goes look how far you have to
go it's really important that you remind
yourself of how far you've come how much
you've grown the difference you've made
with this principle it was actually a
study by amy vrznewski and her team at
the yale school of management they
wanted to go and research what they
believed was the most difficult job in
the world
hospital cleaners and this was
pre-pandemic
these were people who had to clean up
the hospital rooms hospital beds
hospital toilets after people ate and
even often people passed away you can
only imagine what a challenging and
difficult job it is they went and
interviewed some hospital cleaners some
of them described themselves as cleaners
they described the activities that i
just stated and described themselves as
doing that kind of labor now another
group of hospital cleaners they
described themselves as healers
servers carers transformers they did the
same exact work as the other cleaners in
the same hospitals
but they saw themselves as directly
connected towards the healing journey of
the patient and the patient's family
they saw their work that if they could
make an environment clean that that
would be better for the patient and the
patient's family they saw it as a way of
serving
someone's journey towards healing this
mindset which amy brznewski and her team
called job crafting is where you look at
your work differently so many of us get
caught up on that excel spreadsheet we
get caught up on that powerpoint
presentation we get caught up on doing
the actual task
but we forget to look up
look beyond our laptops look beyond our
screens zoom out
and think about the impact that our work
actually has on others
your work may be allowing you to put
food on the table and take care of your
family it may be helping your children
go to a specific school it may be
helping them have certain opportunities
when you look up from the task and you
focus on what your work truly allows you
and the people you love to do
you start looking far beyond than just
that activity think about that today
zoom out and that reduces the anxiety it
reduces the stress that is attached to
the day-to-day task
and allows you to look at it from a
bird's-eye view i think actions that we
should be adding more of in our life are
actions that
create positive habits i think it has to
be habits orientated it has to be stuff
that we can repeat
and and
in think like a monk i talk about the
four key habits in your day which are
thankfulness
inspiration
meditation and exercise which is the
acronym of time
so make more time in your day for
thankfulness inspiration meditation and
exercise those are four actions that i
think if everyone wants to take in their
day
this is what happens when you're
thankful you boost your immunity you
boost your self-confidence you boost
your mood yeah because you go oh people
love me that means i matter people care
about me that means i have something to
care about so it boosts your mood and
then when you tell people that you're
thankful you now boost connection and
relationship and when you thank someone
you now boost the feeling of i have
people in my life that care about me and
i care about them so much comes out of
that one action inspiration or insight
listening to a podcast reading a book
reading a quote when you do that again
you feel excited you feel enthused you
feel like you're learning you feel like
your mind actually works and that they
can go somewhere so that's a great
action meditation of course we've talked
about length in the beginning and
exercise
people just don't understand that we
could solve so many of our
challenges simply by sleep and exercise
and diet like those three things change
your life should change your life and
and we have to just get focused on one
at a time
and so where in actions i i talk about
this thing in principle is we want
things to be small steps but big
priorities so if you want to change an
action in your life it needs to be a big
priority and then you need to break it
down into small steps what we try and do
is we try and change everything at the
same time i think one of the biggest
mistakes i've made
and i think we make as humans is we
often look for
divinity in humanity
you're looking for that divine person
that has all the answers and that is
infallible and perfect
and when you seek divinity in humanity
you're left with
insecurity and anxiety
because no one fulfills that divine
search and so for me what i really had
to understand as i went down that road
and felt like i was let down and felt
like people
made me feel unworthy or unequipped was
i recognized that there were four
pillars of relationships
and they are care
competence
consistency and character
every single person in your life
is going to be able to give you or
should be able to give you at least one
of these four characteristics
very rarely
if ever will one person give you all
four
and if you're lucky you might have a few
people in your life that give you two or
three so let's talk about each of them
care
my mom there is no one in the world who
cares for me more than my mom she would
do anything for me she'd be there for me
all she wants to make sure
doesn't matter what i've achieved or
what i've done if she picks up the phone
to me her first question is have you
eaten
what did you eat uh are you safe are you
healthy right like that's all she cares
about
now my mom isn't the person that i go to
for business advice
or she's not the person i'm saying
hypothetically that i go to for social
media advice that's not her competence
but she doesn't need to be she cares for
me and that's what i get from her
now let's go to competence
if i'm thinking about
starting a business
new dragon over here
right like you'd be a great friend to
call up you're someone who understands
what it takes to get investors scale a
business build teams manage
internationally grow scale sell like you
have that journey and you have that
network you have that career i'd also
care about you i know you also care
about me so i've got two out of four in
you and you've got good character
you don't have the consistency though
because we don't see each other enough
so
so three out of four 35 yeah 75 percent
and so for that for me is that perfect
example if there's competence there and
there is care there which is wonderful
and there's character there i believe
you're someone of good character and
that's the next one character there are
some people in our life that hold us to
higher values
they help us grow with greater integrity
they help us see things beyond what
we're chasing they make us look beyond
our desires and make us recognize that
there's so much more to life and those
people are massively important
and those people may not be the people
we see every week they may not be the
people we see every day they may not be
the people that we call up but you need
them as your compass the people with
character are your compass
and then finally you have the people
that are consistent you have some mates
that you just know are always going to
pick up the phone
you know that if you need to move house
you've got a family emergency you know
which friend you call
they may not be the competent business
advisor
they may care about you but they don't
care about you as deeply as your mom
does but they are consistently always
there for you
and that's beautiful but the problem is
when we look at our consistent friend we
think why are you not competent we look
at our competent friend we think why
don't you have good character we look at
our character friend and say well why
aren't you always there and so we're
always looking for which c they don't
have
rather than appreciating for them for
exactly what they bring to our life on a
mental level what's self-awareness
knowing what type of people i like to be
with knowing who helps me grow and who
drains me that's mental self-awareness
so self-awareness at every level and
then we go into the spiritual
consciousness level
that's disconnecting from all these
identities and understanding the
identity that we are wired for
generosity and we're wired to serve and
only in service can we be happy
and that's us on a consciousness level
that's the identity of consciousness
like water is wet the sun is heating in
light
consciousness is service like that's how
it fits why are we wired for that we're
wired for that because
all of us
as consciousness have been designed and
we see it since like even kids
like i was giving this example of this
beautiful and you may have seen it it is
it went viral on instagram it was this
little girl probably like two years old
watching a cartoon
and she takes a handkerchief and the
cartoon character is crying
and she goes up to the television and
she tries to wipe it off
right and it's it's incredible because
this girl's two years old and she thinks
this cartoon character animal is crying
and she gets a real tissue and tries to
wipe it on the tv obviously it doesn't
work and there's another another one
that i saw with this statue of this
rabbit and there's like four rabbits and
one rabbit's like falling off the end
and this little boy is trying to push
the rabbit up but it's a stone rabbit
it's just a statue but he's going to
help it back up so we see and there was
a great article in wyatt about this
about how we're wired for generosity our
brain is happier in service this whole
world is almost a school an education
system to make us realize that one truth
and we see
that when we're serving when we're doing
that we feel genuine happiness but when
we're trying to gain and greed and power
and strength
we even feel empty as it slips through
our fingers
so the why
is because that allows us to connect to
our deepest self
the happiest self that we have and
modern studies have shown that so
michael norton at cambridge university
he did a study where they gave people
five ten twenty dollars to spend on
themselves have you seen this
yeah and then they spent five ten twenty
dollars on others
so people spent five ten twenty dollars
on makeup starbucks and normal stuff
right that was that that was the three
comments three make up starbucks and
then something else i can't remember
and then people who spent on other
people they also bought others the same
stuff starbucks was still in there
and they're buying all this stuff what
they found is that when people
self-assess their happiness before and
after without knowing about this a b
test
people who spent the money on themselves
didn't feel any happier or any less
happier but the people that spent on
others felt 10 to 20 percent happier
and then he went and tried this out this
was a college in in the united states
that then when it did in africa they did
it all over the world and the stats and
the patterns shared the same wow that
we're wired for generosity we're wired
to serve to make us realize that that's
our real nature that's our greatest
self-awareness i'd say that
in in my heart and my intention
i've only wanted to do good for others
and serve others and support others so
whenever i even when i started creating
content or even when i worked in the
city or when i became a monk
my intention was always to serve and to
help others my intention was never
motivated by
big results or anything that's happened
in my life today i never thought it
would happen and and i never even
believed that that was the goal or that
was the reason i was doing it the reason
i was doing it was i believed that i
uncovered this incredible wisdom and i
wanted to share it that was it and so i
think sometimes our intention gets uh
dirty or messy
uh sometimes really our intention is ego
driven or sometimes it's
money driven or sometimes it's results
driven and none of those things are bad
you can have money you can be famous you
can be successful but if that is your
reason for doing it if that is your
intention for doing it it won't satisfy
you even if you get there
and actually if you do it for a deeper
reason you'll probably get there faster
and you'll be happier when you actually
receive it and so one thing for me is
and i work on this every day it's not
that i've mastered it but every day i'm
working on my intention to always be of
service to always want to help i was
really fortunate to meet incredible
people when i was young i met a few
people that absolutely transformed my
life
i'm eternally indebted to them grateful
to them and
i owe it all to them and so i give all
my success to them you know without
meeting those amazing mentors and those
phenomenal thought leaders and thinkers
who are not famous who are not known who
are not
present like they're not they're not in
the social media world they're not big
names or whatever
those people you know those people
if i never met them none of this would
have happened i can see that's the
emotion in your face when you say this
yeah i just i i really you know we we
skipped it earlier but i i just feel
like
the gratitude that i have for
people who saw potential in me when i
didn't see it myself
that is just the greatest gift you can
give to someone like i today have
self-awareness and i have confidence and
i know who i am and i i wasn't always
like that like there were tons of years
where i was insecure and
you know i was bullied for being
overweight and i was bullied for being
the only indian at school and there was
so much like baggage to do with just
my body my
language i used and all this kind of
stuff and to to have someone notice that
you may have something
i mean you've had that and that is just
you you like honor that person for the
rest of your life and the best thing is
those people don't even want it so you
know the best thing about all of this is
the people there are not going oh yeah
we did that they're actually saying no
no no it's not us like it's you and and
i think that's the beauty of that so i
have to say that i ha it's important
that i share that answer
not because i'm trying to give a more
strategic answer but i think it's
important because it is a big part of it
and so that would be the monks that i
met it would be the coaches that i met
the guys that i met looking at it from a
very practical strategic standpoint
shifting now
my parents forced me to go to public
speaking and drama school when i was 11
years old
and
i really didn't want to go because i was
shy
i was unconfident i was insecure about
being on stage or being in a public
setting i actually loved acting growing
up i really enjoyed acting and doing
theater and things like that where i was
playing another character but being
myself on stage
that was the last thing i wanted to do
and my parents saw that and they saw
that as something that i should work on
so they forced me and my school to
enroll me in a public speaking course
so from the age of 11 through to the age
of 18
for three hours a day three days a week
so nine hours a week for seven years i
went to public speaking school really
for seven years of my life i went to
public speaking school
so when i look back at my ability to
communicate my ability to understand
ideas and by the way public speaking
school is examination based too so we
had exams where they would give you a
topic 15 minutes before you have 15
minutes to research a topic from the
books in the room that they give you
because there was no smartphone at the
time when we were 11 12 years old
and you'd have to create a speech in 15
minutes about that subject from the
books that were in the room
you had to read from a book that you'd
never read before they'd pick a random
page and they'd ask you to read it out
so the examination of a public this was
at the london academy of music drama and
arts it's called lambda
and that's where i studied for seven
years so
that's a very
strategic skill set that i had the time
to develop thanks to my parents you know
like without my parents that none of
that would have ever happened and i
think that's a big part of why people
hopefully appreciate how i communicate
ideas because i've spent a lot of time
understanding communication
but when i was 18 i had nothing to talk
about
so even though i had all these tools and
skills i didn't really use them because
i didn't care about anything so sure i
gave a good presentation at university
and work experience and an internship
but it was never something that brought
me to life and so then when i met the
monks and i got an opportunity to study
the vaders which are 5 000 years old and
again we were put through rigorous study
we sat down we had to learn verses we
had to analyze purports commentaries on
ancient scriptures we had to do
comparative analysis of religions and
tradition like when i was a monk we were
massively trained in philosophical
analysis
and that to me gave me a real strength
and confidence in these ideas so some of
the ideas i present today that may sound
simple they're based on these really
ancient deep truths
that i've had the time to
grapple with with the greats who really
understand them so that to me is a big
benefit i've had where i've had three
years
of
complete dedication to studying
philosophy and not just studying the
intellectual areas but the practical and
the applicable areas as well so thanks
to my monk teachers who gave me that can
you tell me what you do for sleep since
this was an add-on to the uh time
acronym what's your sleep schedule and
what's your uh do you have a a bedtime
and a wake-up routine
yeah for sure so
i and so i love ariana's book sleep
revolution too i think it's unbelievable
if you really want to convince yourself
that sleep is important because i think
a lot of us undervalue sleep or we
undervalue sleep before midnight we
undervalue quality sleep we don't
understand what it means and so i think
it's really important and i think she
has a line in there that says something
like this is how you sleep your way to
the top
and she talks about how you know how
successful people can sleep their way to
the top which i love uh but yeah so for
me sleep is you know i
for a long time obviously living as a
monk we didn't sleep for long but we
meditate for long periods of time which
kind of created that deep sense of rest
but now that i don't have that i have a
very simple schedule where i sleep by 10
p.m and i'm up at 6 00 am
and i really find that eight hours and
15 minutes to be exact is like my sweet
time and i've noticed that i've
measured that and i've checked that to
see what works for me because at times
when i had seven to nine hours i was
like all right let me sleep for seven
and get up and be five and i was
experimenting with seven seven and a
half hours and i found that actually for
me to be my optimal eight hours and 15
minutes is my sweet spot and for a lot
of people they're like wow you're
sleeping a lot that's a lot of time and
i'm like yeah but i'm at my best like
that's what i want why would i want to
sleep seven have an extra hour and 15
minutes but then lose four hours because
i'm unproductive and unhappy and not at
my best that's the opportunity cost that
you have to measure see we're measuring
what could i do with one an hour and 15
minutes my question to you is what's
your energy during that one hour and 15
minutes that you gained from taking it
away from your sleep and and my i
believe that the ability to be
productive in less time is more powerful
than to spread it over more time so
i i do that 10 a.m and 6 a.m is when i
wake up usually i've trained myself
after that 8 hours 15 minutes i know
that's how much i'm going to sleep so i
don't wake up to an alarm
i really enjoy waking up without an
alarm if you need an alarm because you
and i i don't sleep in or snooze in by
the way i'm up at that time because my
body's now used to it but one thing i'd
recommend is don't wake up to your phone
and don't have your phone in your
bedroom before you go to bed so get a
real alarm clock i remember ordering
when i first did this a little timex
alarm clock and i would lock my phone
and my laptop in my car outside so that
i wouldn't even go to them so i would
lock them the night before because it
was so easy for me to just leave my
phone there and so when i wake up in the
morning again i can't look at my phone
my alarm wakes me up and this is one
thing i'd really add
the sound you wake up to
is so important for your mental state
and this is not spoken about enough most
of the sounds that wake up stuff in the
morning whether it's your mom or dad
shouting at you or whether it's a really
annoying alert tone which most phones
have
those are actually shocking you into
being awake you're now waking up with
anxiety and now you're carrying that
anxiety throughout the day waking up to
nature sounds waking up to calming
sounds waking up to the sound of a gong
or symbols or
uh ocean sounds like some sounds like
that are so much better for you to wake
up to because imagine literally like
imagine trying you know how many cars
can get from zero to 60 miles per hour
in two to three seconds not many and
when you're putting your foot on the gas
like that with a jolt and a shock
your body's not waking up in shock and
so i would really be careful about the
first thing you see in the morning
and the first thing you hear in the
morning because those two things those
senses are so powerful i would say my
life is purposeful which has both
elements
so so what i mean by that is
my life is easy because i know what i
want to do what i stand for i know what
i believe in but it's difficult because
i have to put in hours i have to put in
work i have to be organized i have to
live a disciplined life
but discipline funnily enough actually
makes life easier so people think
discipline is difficult
but but the result of discipline is that
life becomes easier and so waking up
every day and meditating
or going to the gym is difficult it's
difficult it's not easy it's it's
challenging
but the result of that is life becomes
easier so i'd say that i'm dedicated
to difficult discipline
but that because it's purposeful and it
has meaning
become makes life easier to live if that
answers your question
it does it does but um and i'm asking
you this for
selfish reasons because i wa i have i
have difficult days even today you know
with with so many blessings around me
established businesses there are days
where i'll wake up
not feeling completely motivated slash
not feeling completely worthy uh i'm
just asking you this kind of as a
younger brother oh yeah for sure bro for
sure i still have that i wake up days
where i feel
stressed where i feel
under pressure where i feel
like i've just got so much to do and
you know i haven't got the support i
need or you know all of that like i i
experience all of that
and and what i say to people is that
training your mind and your body is not
about never feeling that way again it's
not that one day that won't happen
it's that you let it affect you for less
time
so in the past you and me
maybe when it happened when bad things
would happen you'd be thinking about it
for like a whole month
but now when something happens you think
about it for a week
and then in a year from now you'll think
about it for one day and then in a year
from now you'll think about it for one
hour and then a year from now you'll
think about it for one minute and that's
the goal the goal is not
to never feel stress
the goal is to feel it for less and less
time
because
the point is that most of us allow
stress and pressure to consume us
and so the less you let it consume you
is the goal but the problem is that when
you have the goal that i should wake up
and feel perfect every day
that goal puts its own pressure and
stress into your life so i wake up man i
i'm with you like as as you said as a
younger brother which i appreciate you
saying that means a lot to me but as an
older brother like i would say dude i
feel stressed i feel pressure i still
have bad mood swings sometimes
but that's part of it and and that
reminds you how far you have to go
and it keeps you humble and it keeps you
grounded
and also it helps you empathize with
people more because if you never felt
that way and then someone tells me if a
young person comes up to me and says jay
i feel stressed and i'm like oh come on
just get over it like there is no such
thing as stress that's not true and so i
find that when i feel stressed or
fearful or anxious
i explore it a little deeper
so that next time someone says that to
me i can actually feel empathy and
compassion for them because i know how
it feels and so actually i i actually
feel like going through pain is the best
thing for a content creator because
that's how you truly empathize with
people if you don't go through pain then
you can never relate to anyone this is
something i created called the quadrant
of potential
what you'll see here is
the blue section says not good at and
not interested
when you do what you're not good at and
you're not interested in
it feels pointless and it can lead to
depression
when you do what you're not good at and
you're not interested in it can lead to
depression it can lead to anxiety
it can lead to all of those negative
emotions
now look at the yellow section of the
quadrant
not good at but interested there's a lot
of stuff in the world that we're not
good at
but we're interested in for me social
media used to be one of those things
i was interested in social media but i
wasn't good at it but that's something
where you see potential and you feel
excitement
when you're trying to learn something
that you're not good at but you're
interested in you feel a buzz it's
exciting
look at the gray section of the quadrant
the gray section of the quadrant
is good at but don't love that's what
most of us end up doing for work
we do something that we're good at but
we don't really love it it doesn't
fulfill us
and that ends up being a profession but
it stresses us out
and finally in the orange quadrant you
have good at and love
that's where you find passion and that's
where you experience fulfillment
what i'd love for you to do is today
tomorrow sit down with your partner your
friend and actually reflect on two to
three things in each section of that
quadrant
do you know what you're good at and love
do more of that
do you know what that you're not good at
but interested in do more of that
spend your life in the orange and yellow
side of the quadrant and you will never
ever
have to experience that pressure that
stress anxiety in the negative sense
you'll still experience stress and
pressure
i experience stress and pressure but
it's good
it motivates me inspires me not bringing
me down
let's move away from spending time in
the good and don't loved and not good
and not interested i really believe that
the first thought you want to have in
the day is a thought of gratitude so
when we would wake up as monks at 4am
and our collective prayers and
meditations would start at 4 30 a.m the
first prayer of meditation was about
gratitude
and it was engineered in that way
because when you are present in
gratitude you can't be anywhere else
so if you're in a state of gratitude you
can't be in a state of anxiety if you're
in a state of gratitude you can't be in
a state of worry so many of us today
wake up in a state of worry in a state
of anxiety and so if your first thought
can be a thought of gratitude it can
absolutely transform your day and so i'm
actually gonna ask you a question
melissa i want you to name
two friends they can be real or
imaginary but i need two names
um
rachel and amanda okay so rachel and
amanda disclaimer i do not know rachel
and amanda so anything i say about them
from now on is completely fictional but
let's take rachel and amanda so let's
say after all of this code pandemic
lockdown is over melissa and her husband
throw a party and they invite rachel and
amanda now they have a good time and the
next morning
when melissa wakes up and looks at her
phone she sees a text message by the way
not straight away when she wakes up she
does all over morning i do my meditation
meditations and then when she looks at
her phone she sees messages from rachel
and amanda
rachel says and again rachel none of
this is personal or or about you i
promise uh if you're a real person but
rachel says thank you melissa had a
great time
now that's her message and amanda's
message when melissa reads it says
melissa that was amazing what an
incredible party i had the best time
ever the the food was incredible and the
games we played were so fun your your
family and friends are all so beautiful
you know what you made my 2020. this was
amazing thank you so much
now melissa is a grateful person so
chances are she'll feel grateful for
both of those messages
but it's likely that amanda's message is
far more fulfilling to her heart because
that thankfulness for it to truly work
for it to scientifically boost your mood
thankfulness and gratitude needs to be
personalized and specific
so when we say we're grateful for the
air or grateful for our hands or our
body or our life
if it's not specific if it's not
personalized
you don't actually feel the effect of
gratitude
you also don't feel the effect of
gratitude if it just lives in your
journal if it just lives in your heart
and mind it also needs to be expressed
and shared with people it needs to be an
exchange of energy
and so the fact that both her friends
reached out to her is great but the one
that's personalized and specific goes a
step further so remember in your own
gratitude practice and so i try to make
the point every day to choose one person
a day
to send a voice note to a text message
um a voice note a facetime call a video
message whatever it is one person a day
how can i express personalized specific
gratitude
right that's that's all it takes so
that's a really key habit for me and one
point one of your videos got
365 million views right yeah one of them
what was that video that video was a
video where i'm talking about
not rushing people's timelines okay so i
feel like we've got and i was just
speaking to someone this week they're
like 25 years old and they feel the
pressure to be a successful entrepreneur
and have a multi-million dollar business
by age 30 and i'm like
why do you feel that pressure yeah but i
feel like now like you know when you're
21 you've got a pressure why don't you
have a million followers yet when you're
18 you've got a pressure like why am i
not a tick tock star yet right it's like
there were just so much pressure and
that video was all about how like some
of the most successful people in the
world became successful at 40 a 50 at 60
at 70. like there is no timeline on
success don't rush it don't rush it and
don't let anyone rush you yeah because
that's one of the biggest mistakes we
make is we go oh my friends already got
this i need to do it and when you start
living as a reflection of other people
you're not living the life you want
you're living the life they want no
question so that's what the video is
about i think of inspiration like eating
food every day you feel hungry
and you don't panic when you get hungry
you just know you need to find food and
eat but you don't go oh no why do i feel
hungry today i ate so much yesterday and
i ate so much last week i shouldn't be
hungry today like why do i feel hungry
today that's not your panic your panic
is why didn't i plan for my meal right
like that's the panic but you're not
panicking going oh my gosh why am i
hungry i shouldn't be hungry
so it's really strange when we don't
feel inspired or motivated we panic we
go oh no why don't i feel inspired i'm
i'm a negative person like i'm i'm not
motivated like what's wrong with me well
that's because we haven't fed ourselves
and so we have to find something that
inspires us daily you may say
uh it's a quote that you see that you
write your favorite quote and you put on
a post-it note next to your bed when you
wake up in the morning it may be a
paragraph from a book it may be
listening to this podcast
two of my best habits for inspiration
with these two that i want to share with
you melissa one of them was around
i probably said like around seven years
ago when i left the
when i left monk life i would every day
i would listen to steve jobs stanford
commencement speech every single day to
the point where i almost knew off by
heart
and i cannot tell you how much that
rewired the voice in my head
and how much of that speech has inspired
every step and decision i've made today
i had the fortune the other day of
sitting down with matthew mcconaughey on
my podcast i was interviewing him for it
i think the episode comes out next
monday
and
i was telling him that at one point in
my life in about 2014 2015
i listened to his oscars acceptance
speech and it's about five minutes and i
would listen to it every single day for
30 days and it was so profound listening
to the same thing again and again and
again to rewire my mind so inspiration
can come in all ways whether you're a
auditory learner or a kinesthetic
learner or a visual learner the point is
you have to feed yourself every day
don't gamble they found that 77 of those
who struggle financially play the
lottery right they play the game they
gamble 77
of people who are struggling financially
gamble the advice is don't gamble if
you're gambling right and you're not
winning a lot maybe you're an online
poker player right maybe you're playing
for entertainment that's different but
still be careful but maybe you're
someone who's hoping that you're going
to get a quick rich scheme a lot of
these quick rit schemes online aren't
real right and and gambling is just the
more obvious version of that where it's
all gamified it feels exciting but they
found that 77
of people that are struggling
financially gamble right so the advice
was don't gamble don't focus in on that
pain makes us pay attention
right like pain makes you pay attention
i'll give an example if you're like if
you've got a little cut here
you you may not think anything of it if
the card gets bigger and it starts to
sting you take it a bit more seriously
now if this if it gets infected then
you're like okay i need to do something
about it and often there are these signs
in our life there are always signs
signals and reminders in our life they
are always there
but they're so quiet
and we're so loud that we don't hear
them
and so then those signals have to get
louder and deeper and harder to finally
get our attention because we're not
present with ourselves the only way our
body and mind get us to be present is
through pain
and so the only antidote is to be
proactively present with ourselves
is to actually sit with our emotions is
to actually get to know ourselves
intimately and personally because if
we're always rushing around and moving
around
our body and mind don't have the time to
tell us what's going on we don't listen
to our mind and body because we're too
busy
and so when we finally listen to our
body and mind
then we get an opportunity to address
what's going on so to me that's why pain
makes us
stop and realize and forces it to happen
tragedy transforms us because it forces
us to pay attention
but we can change that
by proactively being present with our
mind and body and that's how we can
create that urgency without the pain and
without the tragedy so before i ever
made a video i pitched my video series
idea to 40 media companies and i was
rejected by every single one of them
before an interview because i didn't
have a media or journalism background or
a hosting background or a communications
background and so 40 of the top media
companies said no immediately they
didn't even meet me they didn't take the
time i then chased two editors of huge
magazines and online magazines in london
one of them i chased while he was riding
his bike across london the other i
networked with at an event and i begged
them both for jobs and i said look just
give me a break i just need an
opportunity and this was when i was 28
years old three years ago and they both
said to me they said you're too old to
be in media like this is not going to
happen everyone trying to break through
is 21 years old it's not going to happen
so i had literally multiple doors closed
in my face before i even made a video
and i ended up this is in 2013 2014 this
is 2016. 2016 2016. and then i ended up
at a ethnic minority tv training day run
by the bbc in london and i walked into
this room and there were six colored
people in there and i was like oh i'm
brown you're brown and you're brown and
black and you know it was literally like
it was a room full of ethnic minorities
in in london and this was run for us and
they trained us in presenting i went
there to see if i even had the skills
and then afterwards they were just like
yeah jay you're great like you could do
this i was like great you have a job for
me and they said no no no no there's no
jobs in media and i was like okay great
so i got to a point where i'd exhausted
all options apart from starting a social
media page so i launched my first video
on social media on facebook and youtube
in 2016 just three years ago and what
were you doing outside of hustling in
that moment
i was doing a lot of corporate coaching
i was what gave you the confidence after
the after being rejected by 40 media
companies and being told that you're
good but there's no jobs what still gave
you the confidence to keep going the
only thing that gave me the confidence
was this principle of thought by thomas
edison which was when you believe you've
exhausted all options remember this you
haven't and i was saying to myself that
unless i've genuinely knocked on every
single door
i can't say to anyone that i haven't had
a chance
and so my confidence came from the fact
that i was going to try and knock on
every different door walk down every
different path and see what was possible
and that's my biggest advice to everyone
today is that we no longer need
permission from anyone to give us an
opportunity to share our voice the
audience and community can decide for
themselves
you've got people waiting on social
media for content the people will decide
for you
and so for all of us today we have this
unique opportunity if you've not done
something for yourself every day yeah if
you've not taken your time to invest in
yourself every day and that isn't just a
you know it's it comes so much from
understanding yourself and understanding
yourself comes from the place of knowing
yourself and getting to know yourself
and most of us spend so much time
codependency trying to get to know
someone else and what their needs are
anticipate their needs and then
shape-shift so that i can be what i
think you want totally evolve
yeah evolve and transmorph into this
person that will be the best for them
but what about if you did that for
yourself to start with and so most of us
don't even know what we want to eat for
dinner on a given day or like what our
favorite movies are we struggle we sit
there for like hours trying to figure
out what to watch because we haven't
really got to know ourselves and so to
me getting to know yourself is very
basic after you eat a meal ask yourself
did i enjoy that what did i like about
it did i feel great 24 hours after
reading it after watching a movie what
did i like about it why did i enjoy it
those basic questions will give you a
much deeper understanding of yourself
the challenge is that we think
things
come with emotions
feelings we think things come with
feelings and emotions and guess what
they don't so if you chase money well
they might for a moment right or they
won't
i don't think they even do also it's
such a false sense of feeling i don't
maybe for a moment but it's so
short-lived that it's it's not even
worth counting almost so it's like when
you
when you think that i'm chasing money
guess what you will get money yep and
that's great money is really important
and money is a really important resource
but guess what money is not now going to
fill that gap that void that feeling
that emotion that you're missing in your
life what are most people missing
we're missing a deep sense of love i
think i think the biggest need in the
world as we've heard many times before
from all the ancient texts they they
summarize it like this to love and be
loved like that is the need of humanity
to love and be loved and when we don't
experience that we then start looking
for status we then start looking for
money then we then start looking for
recognition just to help us give the
feeling a false sense of love correct
and the challenge is because most of us
didn't experience that from our parents
and this is the key thing
what we crave in life
is what we did
or didn't get from our parents what our
parents did give us is what we continue
to crave what they didn't give us is
what we continue to crave so you'll find
that most people's love languages that
they chase
are things that their parents didn't
give them so if their parents didn't
give them time they now crave everyone's
time if their parents didn't give them
gifts they'd crave gifts if their
parents didn't give them
acts of service they're craving those
acts of service so it's because of our
childhood
and if we don't learn
to process all of that experience which
most people never get the time to do and
i empathize with that because i've had
to go through that i've seen me
repeating my parents patterns i've
something you were craving so i would
crave a big thing for me was i would
crave surprises and gifts because that's
your thing yeah that's my thing still is
your thing it's still my face yeah and
and i did your parents not do that for
you no they did it my mom did a lot of
it that's why you're still crying
correct so my mom would always every
year on my birthday
she'd always surprised me with the one
thing i wanted and i wasn't spoiled
growing up i didn't have a lot growing
up but she would get that one thing
whether it was like a power rangers toy
or whether it was whatever it was you
know something yeah
yeah things you want as a kid right and
she would always surprise me with that
and that became so deep rooted now i'll
give you an example when i then married
my wife
you just expect people to know that that
they're going to do the same thing
totally actually
no because i'm expecting my wife to be
like my mom in the sense of i expected a
surprise or show me love in the same way
and she doesn't know that she's not a
mind reader i can't explain expect her
to know that so it took communication it
took time for me to explain that so
spirituality and business is an
interesting concept because a lot of
people today see it as an oxymoron yeah
or
you know mutually exclusive
and the truth is that spirituality is so
powerful that it actually spreads across
everything and i know i know all of you
understand that but it's like
if spirituality is what we all say it is
then it has the purity and the power
to spread across anything
and again going back to our previous
theme the key element
is is this for service of humanity for
others or is this in the service of
myself now that's a fine line yeah and
i've been on the wrong side of that line
plenty of times so there's plenty of
times when i assess options and
opportunities in front of me and i
realize i'm only taking that option
because there's ego involved
i'm only taking that option because
there's an opportunity or there's a big
payout or there's a nice
dollar sign next to it and i'm only
doing it for that and i've said yes to
stuff like that plenty of times to know
that i'm not perfect but the awareness
is what i would encourage people to do
is is having the ability to be like here
are the three four options in my life
right now
let me write a word above them which is
the intention of why i'm choosing that
and if if the word isn't love
or service
it's not going to feel good after i
finish it
and and so that's that's what i would
encourage people to do as a reflection
without needing anyone in their life or
anyone around them and i said this is
this is a monk statement that we used to
repeat i said i'm just not going to
judge the moment
don't judge the moment because what we
do is we try to label moments as good or
bad and when you label the moment as bad
it now does not have the opportunity to
become good i'll give an example if i go
i don't like this book this book's bad
right and i don't and i love this book
but if i say that guess what i will
never pick it up and recognize the value
that's inside of it because you've
labeled it yes and we label stuff like
we label or that restaurant's bad
but when you label them
that person's bad now you can't learn
from that person oh great one that's a
really good one
as soon as you start labeling people or
anything is good or bad you limit it you
stop it from being something else and
here's the truth
every moment can evolve into being
anything if you give it the opportunity
to right but as soon as you say it's got
no value anymore you lose it
and so for me i had to say to myself
don't judge the moment and i'd keep
repeating that don't judge where you're
at don't judge what's happening yeah
don't judge it as negative don't don't
just start saying it's negative because
guess what we've all been in positions
where a gift turned into a curse and a
curse turned into a gift true right
we've already our dreams came true and
it ended up not being what we wanted
exactly it fell apart and it led us into
our dream totally why is it that so many
people that win the lottery go broke no
gifts can turn into curses too but
because we label them as the best moment
in our life or the worst moment in our
life whereas when you approach things to
neutrality and just what you have on the
table you can be like okay what am i
going to do next i had the fortune of
interviewing walter isaacson he's
famously known to write the biographies
of the biggest icons of all time so he
wrote the official biography of leonardo
da vinci einstein steve jobs like you
know just it's insane and he worked at
cnn in time before that
and he wrote a new book about a lady
named jennifer doudner who is the
founder of gene editing
now she's a
female scientist who was told by her
school teachers that women don't become
scientists
right like women's can't be scientists
she just won the nobel prize for for her
discovery so amazing and he just wrote a
book about her life it's called code
breaker
the reason why i'm sharing all of that
is that
some
girl is going to pick up that book or
guy both or anyone or they are going to
pick up that book
and they are going to find their role
model in that book
we all find we may not have a monk on
speed dial we may not have met a monk
when you're 18 but you're going to find
when you start searching and looking and
when you find that you're going to read
it you're going to internalize it and
it's going to change how you think and i
just feel that encouraging people to
find
coaches guides and mentors is the best
thing i can do because there's no one we
admire that doesn't have that whether
they're an athlete
whether they're a singer whether a
musician whether they're a videographer
or editor everyone's had mentors guides
and coaches but it's become so
far removed from our lives today that
everyone thinks they have to figure it
out for themselves and that's where the
mess is created from it sounds like an
obvious point but it's almost like we
obviously haven't pushed it enough right
because as a man to take another person
as your mentor also requires you
to have humility you've got to forgive
yourself you've got to be compassionate
to yourself so the simple act of taking
on a mentor
actually does more for your masculinity
than anything else half the reason why
we don't get started is we
you know put this
big plan or big next step ahead of like
okay now i have to yeah like you said
like go and build this new cafe and
we're going to have 12 on every street
corner in new york city and it's going
to be the next big thing and you know
who can live up to that and i think the
same was for me i wasn't judging myself
for living
trying out two lives i wasn't judging
myself for my mistakes and maybe i did
judge myself at that time but i learned
now to just release myself of that
judgment and allow myself to experience
and explore
without putting that in even in this
time that we're in right now like i
think i'm you know encouraging people to
just explore and experiment at this time
rather than judge yourself or feel
guilty because guess what none of us
planned for this no one knew was
happening
and that's kind of life in general but
we're all feeling at the same time right
now
and so you can't expect yourself to have
a plan but you can allow yourself to
explore experience and experiment
and that's actually what's going to help
you find the plan or what you want to
focus on rather than forcing yourself to
feel you need to focus right now how
much of a
positive environment
supports us in our growth or holds us
back there are some people who have the
perfect family situation resources
beautiful backyards and nature
who are lazy
and there are others who have
you know divorced parents
abusive parents
abusive friends an environment of a
desert yeah and they figure out a way to
thrive totally how much importance does
our environment play in our overall
success
if you look at the examples that you
just shared and you really analyzed life
you'd see very little because you see
people craft their own life so a good
example for me is that when i came back
from living in the ashram
and there were other people who may have
been monks who'd also left the path and
i came back to a
not financially successful or supportive
family so my family doesn't have
abundant wealth and couldn't necessarily
have taken care of me or paid for me
forever and i had to figure out my own
life and that to me was a great sense of
impetus and incentive to go and figure
it out and learn new skills and network
and meet people and i saw other friends
who'd parents had like a property
portfolio with like 10 properties ready
to hand them over they had a bmw the
second that they
came out whatever you know from their
own life or i even have friends that had
all of that and didn't become monks and
didn't even find careers so i've also
got friends that i went to school with
that today don't even have
careers even though their parents were
really well established right which has
all of these examples have continued me
to believe that we truly
have influence in our more than our
environment our environment affects us
for sure it plants seeds and weeds into
our life but there is still a choice
and and i think even if you feel there
isn't a choice
simply by accepting that there is it
means you have a chance to get out of
there and i think that's what because if
you don't accept that there is then
you're just going to stay stuck correct
like there's been so many times in my
life and there's a beautiful uh quote
from edison
i don't think i said this last time but
if i did it's worth repeating he said
that when you believe you've exhausted
all options remember this you haven't
and the reason why i love that is your
mind continuously feels stuck
when it's tried the obvious and that's
why a lot of creativity and focus
studies say that the first 10 ideas that
come to your mind are never the most
interesting it's when you get into the
11th idea that you start breaking the
pattern and so if someone asks you oh
what's your best business idea your
first 10 ideas are probably not that
innovative and so the mind constantly
gets stuck on that train
and you've got to keep reminding
yourself that there is another door
there could be another pathway i was
thinking about a piece of advice that so
one of my closest spiritual mentors who
was in london
i knew him since i was probably like 12
and probably went since i was 18. he
passed away this year from stage 4 brain
cancer
and he had brain cancer for about i
think like three
three four years now and so
i hadn't really had a real interaction
with him for the past few years because
every time i saw him he wasn't fully
functioning in his short-term memory his
long-term memory was there but his
short-term memory wasn't
and i remember speaking to him probably
about seven eight years ago
and asking him the question i said to
him you know i've got so many ideas
there's so many things i could do
where do i start
and he said this beautiful thing to me
he said you know what your role should
be to open up every door possible
and he said let the world close the
doors you're not meant to walk through
and walk through the ones that remain
open
and what i realize is most of us just
not opening up enough doors because we
think we only have the option of two
doors we look at life as binary zero and
one zero and one right it's just the
same
this or that and i mean i i think you'd
say this too about you and every guest
you've ever had on
i don't think life is ever this or that
it's like this that and that and maybe
that and that and there's always a gap
you've been able to separate
how a video does or performs from my own
your own self-worth oh for sure i think
that is really kind of the key and the
question for when that tick tock or that
instagram video turns off
they're left with themselves yeah and
you know one of the things you teach is
being with yourself but if they don't
know how to be with themselves
so i guess this is this is an
opportunity i'm asking you to
to talk to them if someone's listening
right now
who's struggling with that because i
have struggled with it especially from a
service perspective like i'm here to be
of service why am i making this about
why do i care why should i care i don't
care do i care i do care
i care too much no i didn't get you know
and it's like should i post that no but
this is my platform i want to post
whatever i want i want to post a picture
of the sunset but no one's going to like
the picture of the sunset justin
and and i've had these conversations
with myself and the fact that i'm having
them drive me crazy and you just strike
me as somebody who doesn't have them as
much the philosophical answer and and
the more spiritual answer
is
i'm flawed
i do seek validation in what people
think of me i do
uh
get upset if someone doesn't like my
videos and like someone else's
and i forgive myself i'm compassionate
and i start over again
like that's just the real answer like
that's just the truth
i mess up i i fall down
i get that i'm
i i do get worried about oh well will i
be relevant next year
oh i do get worried about like oh will
people care about me i do get worried
about like have i said anything good on
this podcast right now like is there
anything that i've said that is actually
even worth this podcast i do think about
that like every time i think about that
every time i record a solo episode of my
podcast
and i think about it all the time but
what do i do i allow myself to feel that
allow myself to experience it
i forgive myself for judging myself and
then i start again and i start every day
as if it was new
and my wife and i have this amazing
ability we both have it is that we can
go to sleep forget the night before and
start again and i think that my memory
literally does that i erase
all of my failures and mistakes from the
day before and just start afresh every
day because it's the only way i know
to allow myself to have another go at it
just the idea of allowing yourself to
have some compassion for yourself and i
think everyone who's sitting out there
who's judging themselves accept that you
judge yourself be compassionate but then
seek to redirect that energy whatever
table you're at
and whoever's at that table is what you
judge yourself by i spent years of my
life working really hard from monday to
friday
only to have to wake up on a saturday to
do all my cleaning not only did that
take up the whole day it made less time
for social interaction for connecting
with friends and family and even time to
work on my passions and what ended up
happening is that by the time it was
monday again the house felt unclean and
i felt like i'd made no progress
initially we all believe that doing it
in one day seems like the best method
it's out of sight out of mind you don't
have to think about it for the whole
week and in one day you get it sorted
the challenge with that is that in your
mind it also feels like a bigger
mountain to climb scheduling it out
during the week makes all the difference
tackling small tasks putting things back
immediately after using them washing a
plate immediately after eating something
makes it so much simpler one of the best
ways to do this is to create days
dedicated to specific things this makes
it feel like a challenge or an
experiment so for example a wipe down
wednesday knowing that all you have to
do is wipe down your surfaces may take
no more than five to ten minutes i also
really love floor fridays now the floor
can sometimes take a bit longer but
still scheduling out around 30 minutes
to do that could make all the difference
and if you live with more than one
person you can divide these days and
these areas between you so that you can
make it simpler and easier to handle and
tackle there's quite a few benefits to
this when we do the same thing at the
same time on the same day every single
week it becomes so much easier for the
mind to tackle that task when we divide
and dissect our tasks up in this way we
avoid burnout we avoid feeling like we
have this big huge mountain to climb and
solve and we start tackling elements
every single day when you're feeling
anxious what's happening is that your
mind is either rushing to the past
or it's predicting and projecting the
future so you're either anxious about
something that you experienced before or
you're feeling really nervous and
anxious about something that might or
could happen in the future the best way
to come back into the present moment is
the five four three two one method
you want to start off
by looking around wherever you are and
noticing the five things you can see it
could be the windows
the walls the ceilings you then want to
focus on the four things you can touch
it could be something you're wearing and
you really want to feel the texture it
could be what you're sitting on just
noticing it and really grounding
yourself and holding on to that then
it's about three things you can hear it
could be nothing it could be white noise
then the two things you can smell in
hell could be a scent you're wearing it
could be a flower and then finally the
one thing you can taste
when you practice this it brings you
back into the present moment
and helps you not focus on the anxiety
of the nervousness but on taking action
from exactly where you are there was a
ceo
of a very large car manufacturer and he
was known to be extremely successful
very productive very effective
but the one thing he was failing at is
that his employees really didn't like
working for him because he worked late
how many of you feel that way
oh perfect that's good so no one here
finishes late all everyone's managers
are in the room
whichever way you want to take it it's
up to you right it's up to you uh i
don't know
so
that was one of his challenges that his
his employees hated work for him because
they all left late because of him he
used to work until 10 p.m every evening
so they would leave just after him true
story right they used to leave just
after him
so one of his
assistants she came and said this to him
she said you know morale's a bit down
everyone's struggling at work you know
we're losing a few people a few people
are quitting their work you know people
they're not well they don't feel like
their health is being taken care of
they're not spending enough time with
their families you really need to
consider this
he said okay leave it with me we'll
figure it out we'll figure it out
from the next week on a monday
this gentleman who left at 10 pm every
night got up out of his desk at 6 p.m he
packed his bag switched off his computer
left the office jumped into his car and
all the employees at this time are like
peeking out the window you know just
like making sure like figuring out where
is this guy going pulls into this
beautiful car pulls out and drives away
from the building
is the first time it ever happened at 6
pm
they all decided to wait till 7 pm
before they left
they waited and they left
on tuesday the same thing happened they
looked out the window again he left at 6
pm again this time they wait till 6 45
and they left
they did the same thing and this
happened for three months where he left
at 6 p.m every day
three months later his assistant who
made him aware of this challenge she
came back to him and she said to him i'm
really confused about something she said
you've been leaving four hours earlier
every single day but you're not behind
on your calls you're not behind on your
emails and you're still performing at
the same level if not better than when
you were leaving on time and she said
how are you managing to do this are you
working at home
how are you managing this he said let me
tell you something interesting
he said every day i get into my car at 6
p.m i drive out he said i take a drive
for an hour he said i take that drive i
listen to music i re-energize he said i
sometimes go for a bit of a walk at the
park as well he said i come back fresher
at 7 00 pm and i work for three more
hours
and he said if it helps them knowing
that i've left at 6 p.m so that they can
have a better life and have the values
that they want and value what they want
to give their time to
that doesn't mean i've got to give up
what i value my time to he said i love
my work i love being here till 10 p.m
i'm extremely ambitious i love being
here but they should also love being
where they are
and that to me is a
incredible example
of how someone actually lives foregoing
the perception of others even though he
changed his own life to help other
people they'll never perceive him that
way they just think he's changed his
mind and he goes home early they don't
realize the struggle that he's putting
in and that's what i've realized whether
you're putting in struggle or sacrifice
never look for the validation or
approval of others
to validate that sacrifice or that
struggle
because they don't need to understand
anyway it's always been your inner
journey it's always been part of your
inner growth and i remember when i made
a decision to become a monk after
business school all my friends were like
what the hell are you doing right we
just finished and everyone was going off
to work at goldman sachs and different
banks consulting firms etc i think a few
people came to google as well
and they all said to me they said they
said what do you mean you're becoming a
monk like what does that mean like who
graduates and thinks about that and i
remember having to detach and when i
reflect and i'd love for you to do this
reflect on some of the best decisions
you've made on your life
ask yourself
what decision did you make
what did people say about it and what
was going on in your mind i've learned
through doing that exercise it's a much
longer exercise it can take days and we
do it in our coaching exercises i've
learned that the best decisions in my
life have been the biggest risks
everyone's disagreed with me but i've
been hell-bent on making it happen
and so now when i see an opportunity
like that i do it because i've realized
that that's the pattern of the
philosophy of my life when i make
decisions that are big risks no one
agrees with me
and it doesn't fit with what society is
saying those work out to be my best
decisions in life
and i'm not saying that that's your
pattern i'm saying that you have a
pattern and a rhythm as well and it's
part of your journey to find it after
i've completed my work day when i
finished all of my tasks the last thing
i do is check my schedule for the next
day now i'm one of those people that
follows their schedule to a tea i
believe it makes life simple when i get
my schedule out and look at the next day
i can think about how i'm going to feel
have i got too much or too little on
that do i want to add or edit something
it gives me perspective and allows me to
get a glance on the next day so i can
rearrange or reorganize based on the
energy i feel today sometimes we feel so
tired and exhausted but without making
that change and edit we take that
exhaustion in the next day the other
reason why i like looking ahead is that
it gives me an opportunity to mentally
prepare i may have a podcast the next
day and there's a guest that i'm really
excited about and i may have to calm my
nerves or sometimes it's an event or a
meeting that i'm looking forward to and
i just want to go over the bullet points
before i go to bed it gives me an
opportunity to rehearse the day in
advance and often i'll even sit and do a
short visualization just to imagine how
tomorrow will look terry pratchett a
famous author whether you've already
stuff or not a famous author he said
that people feel
that stories are defined by people but
actually it's the other way around
people are defined by stories
when you're listening to me today i've
shared so many stories with you because
we define ourselves by the stories we
tell ourselves on a daily basis the
story you wake up to will be the story
that will be the story of your day
right if you wake up and you tell
yourself a positive story you'll have a
positive day you wake up tell yourself a
negative story you'll have a negative
day positive and negative thoughts are
like seeds that either grow weeds or
plants
right
they grow inside of us throughout the
day any time you plant something it's
like planting a seed and the more you
water it the more you think about it
grows and of course it's negative it's
like a weed and it starts to grow and
grow and grow and of course won't bear
fruits
so really think about that tell yourself
the right stories connect with the right
stories because ultimately the universe
is made up of stories not atoms and
numbers right we all love stories we
read stories your life is a living story
that you're writing every day and i
genuinely mean that when i first joined
the ashram i was asked to do a lot of
cleaning and in the beginning i found it
tedious and a waste of time what if i
could be serving humanity what if i
could be reading a book what if i could
be studying and making notes and i had
all these excuses in my mind but of
course i'd chosen to be a monk and
therefore i was encouraged to clean
and i started to find that cleaning did
so much for my mind and recently i
looked at some studies that actually
backed that up there are so many
benefits of cleaning in a physical space
that will also clear out your mind a
recent study from ucla by saxby and
reperty found that cleaning gives you a
better sense of control over your
environment and engages your mind in a
repetitive activity that can have a
calming effect
[Music]
what
i'm wearing
[Music]
[Music]
no
we're like just i think this is the fun
of it
okay so we did it here it goes uh
really proud of what we did it was fun
it was fun doing it
i was excited to come to this
conversation thank you because i'm gonna
get to learn from you we're gonna bond
we're gonna you know deepen our
connection like i'm gonna make a new
friend like i wanna be around that
energy i don't wanna walk into
environments where i'm constantly
feeling like oh god why am i here yeah
you know and so
we hear it all the time but genuinely
your relationships harvard's 75 year old
study suggests that human relationships
is the number one reason people are
happy or not i went to sardinia earlier
this year
middle of last year sardinia's in italy
it's a blue zone blue zones are the
places where people live the longest in
the world and the most amount of people
live over a hundred the number one
reason they said that is community
community community that's a big reason
why people live longer and live happier
lives so for me it's find that human
connection in community and please don't
settle for your family like it doesn't
have to be a family like
you know there are there are friends and
then there's family and then there are
friends that become family and my point
is go find that community like so many
people are like i hear this all the time
jay my family is negative i'm surrounded
by a negative environment i'm like yeah
but we don't live in a world where
that's your only option anymore yeah you
can find tribes and communities anywhere
and when i look at forgiveness i define
forgiveness in this way to help you
the stages of forgiveness how many times
even in the past did someone hurt you
and you said i'm gonna get my revenge
in that voice
in front of a mirror
and recorded it no that's not
any intention
that starts with revenge
will lead to pain
just understand that for a moment any
intention that you plan based on revenge
will ultimately not fulfill you
because revenge means the same person
that broke you has to fix you
and when we want revenge we want the
same person that broke us to fix us
because we're doing revenge which means
we want to show them how we change and
how we did it and how we got it right
and when you try and do that guess what
if that person doesn't feel you got it
right
you're still carrying it
if that person doesn't feel you got the
best revenge body if that the person
doesn't feel you've got the best revenge
business if that person doesn't feel you
got the best revenge car
you won't be satisfied
because revenge means that your metric
your reference point is still that
person
the person who broke you cannot fix you
and you do not fix yourself by breaking
someone else what's one thing that we
can do for more wealth so more abundance
in all the areas of our life
so there's a beautiful beautiful
sanskrit word named mudata
and mudata means to feel
joy in others success
so it's been described that
we know how to feel pain when other
people feel pain
that's what we call empathy or
compassion
but we don't know how to feel joy when
other people feel joy
and in think like a monk i talk about
this because i talk about how there are
an infinite number of seats
in the theater of happiness
but because we live in a finite world
we have believed that there are only
x number of tickets in that concert
there are only x number of seats limited
number of seats in that sports game
there are only this many people that
have the opportunity to be abundant
wealthy and successful
and as soon as you put a limit in your
mind and believe that there are only a
finite number of seeds you can't enjoy
the show
and so mood it is the perspective of
saying if i can feel joy
for someone else's success and realize
that takes nothing away from me
because there's infinite number of seats
and actually forget infinite number of
seats there is a seat with your name on
it
there are tickets with your name on it
in the theater of happiness sitting
there waiting for you but because you
want someone else's seat so bad because
you're chasing someone else's seat so
bad and they're already sitting on it
your seat's lying there empty
and so if you just claim your seat
and so if we can experience other
people's joy if we can uh
look to celebrate other people's
successes and joys then then
that will open up abundance in our life
a because we're now part of their
success have you ever noticed that when
you celebrate someone else's success
you're a part of their success so you're
doing that second you get to learn from
their journey see when you're envious or
you compare you don't get to learn so
you've lost everything whereas when you
celebrate someone you get to go what did
they do right
notice how if you're criticizing someone
who's one or you're negative towards
them you go oh well they've got i've got
nothing to learn from them it was easy
from them who cares about them but if
you go wait a minute
they got something right what did they
do you can learn from them so the first
thing is you're a part of their success
the second thing is you learn from them
or their journey
and the third thing is you realize that
there's a seat with your name on it and
if you can do that abundance and wealth
and everything will come
and you start to follow your own path as
the gita says which i quote in the book
it's better to follow your own path
imperfectly than to try to pursue
someone else's path perfect perfectly
and so allowing yourself to just chase
that seat that has your name on it is
far better than trying to get in someone
else's seat the incredible thing about
gratitude is that when you're present in
gratitude you can't be anywhere else
that means that if you're having a
thankful thought you can't have a worry
thought if you're having a grateful
thought you can't have an anxious
thought what an incredible creation
gratitude and thankfulness has to be
practiced in a particular way
it has to be first of all expressed
keeping a gratitude journal is wonderful
writing down what you're grateful for is
beautiful but it's only when you express
it that it starts to have the impact
that i'm speaking about
the second way it has to be practiced is
it has to be specific it has to be
specific to the person it has to be
something specific that happened
recently that's current or even if it
happened in the past
and the third is it has to be
personalized it has to be something that
you'd only say to them it's not
something that you could send to 20
people and they could all feel it was
about them
let me give you an example two people
come to your home for a party they both
text you the day after the party the
first person texts you that said jay
thanks so much the second person texts
me and they said jay we had an amazing
time we loved meeting all your friends
we loved meeting your family it was such
a great time and the food was out of
this world thank you so much obviously
taradi and the games that we played were
just so much fun it was the highlight of
my year
which message is going to make you feel
more loved and cared for
obviously it's the second
because it's not only expressed but it's
specific and it's personalized now the
amazing thing about gratitude given in
that way is that not only is the
receiver happy but the giver is so much
happier as well the bond that you create
when you share that type of thankfulness
will start to reduce anxiety in your
life because it boosts your immune
system it boosts your mood and it boosts
your relationships there's a beautiful
quote from the dalai lama where he said
that
we're born to help people
and if we can't help them let's at least
not hurt them
and i think that's the intention that
you want to leave every person
happier than you found them
leave every place cleaner than you found
it
leave every project
more productive than you found it like
you want to feel that
if you couldn't uplift something or
someone at least don't pull it down
and i think that when you live like that
in your intention people feel that this
isn't necessarily something that you
even have to say or do people feel that
when you just leave a place and all you
wanted to do was give your energy in a
positive way so to me intention is just
coming from a place of how do i leave
every person just a little bit happier
than i found them i don't have to change
their lives right but i try not to hurt
them try not to hurt them how overcoming
failure or even life in general for this
whole process is an inner journey and
i'll explain what i mean by that one of
our biggest challenges with failures
is that we start worrying about others
approval and validation how many of you
feel that way right be honest how many
of you feel that way right we all feel
that way that we're worried about
breaking the mold because of what people
would say we're worried about taking a
risk because we don't know how someone's
going to react right last week i was
doing a facebook live q a and i was
asked a conversation we had about 2 2000
people joining in for about half an hour
and one of them asked me this question
and it stayed with me ever since i did
it and they asked me this question they
said what's the most difficult thing
you've ever overcome in life
right what's the most difficult thing
you've ever overcome in life through my
head ran sports injuries ran health
challenges ran emotional challenges you
know all these different thoughts ran
through my head and then this answer
came to me and the answer came to me and
i said to myself it's not even something
i've overcome but i felt it was the
right thing to share
i said that one of the most important
things or one of the most difficult
things that any of us can overcome and i
haven't overcome it is living for the
perception of others
that's actually one of the most
difficult things we can overcome when we
forego the voice of our ego and tune
into the voice of our intuition
right a voice of our ego says what will
people say the voice of our ego says is
what if you don't make it the voice of
our ego says this part will be safer
this path is better trodden on
and the voice of our intuition is saying
but you don't love that you love this
this is your heart's calling this is
what's going to make you happy every day
this if you can make this work
it will be phenomenal and that's why i
always remind myself and i've been
saying this to myself for years when
i've done jobs i didn't like when i've
done jobs that were okay and i've done
jobs i've always said to myself i'd
rather die trying to make a difference
and not succeed
then don't try at all it's always been a
mantra i've repeated to myself i'd
rather die trying to make a difference
and not succeed than not try at all
because what's exciting is the journey
of everyday growing and becoming the
person i think i need to be
to attract the goal that i want that's
more exciting to me than even reaching
that goal
believing every day that it's possible
believing that it's possible looking at
the limitless possibility and working in
that way therefore a lot of the
challenges we have are simply to give us
responsibility for the success that
we're about to take on
right
pressure creates diamonds right pressure
creates diamonds it's not possible to
have these beautiful diamonds without
pressure and therefore for all of us
there's different ways that we'll be
pressurized in our inner journey but
learning that it's in a journey is
extremely open important and what i mean
by that is foregoing the perception of
others and it's that you can climb up a
ladder
but is it against the right wall are you
climbing up a wall that you actually
want to climb up if you climb up the
left-hand side of the wall but that
wasn't the place you wanted to be at at
the top there's no point of being at the
top
and one of the reasons why we
procrastinate and overthink
is because what we're chasing isn't
meaningful enough it's not purposeful
enough it's not fulfilling enough we
don't realize that we're just trying to
get up the wrong wall and we never take
the first step because we don't actually
care
put your ladder
against a wall that you care about
climbing i know that when i deeply care
about the pain or suffering of another
that i want to help support or serve
that gets me out of bed more than any
other procrastination technique or hack
in the entire world inspiration helps us
deal with anxiety because when we're
feeling inspired when we're feeling
motivated we're able to use that emotion
to help navigate the anxious emotions
we're having the way i like to get
inspired is by listening to audiobooks
it's also by listening to incredible
speeches recently i had the fortune of
interviewing matthew mcconaughey on my
podcast on purpose and i said to him
that at one point in my life i used to
listen to his oscars acceptance speech
from around 2015 every single day it's
only five minutes i would listen to in
the morning and it would give me this
boost of inspiration instead of starting
my mornings with looking at my phone and
opening my mind up to news notifications
negativity and noise i was starting my
day with an inspirational word maybe an
inspirational paragraph from a book you
love or an inspirational quote your
whole podcast is about on purpose
what's the difference between
discovering your purpose finding your
purpose living it and living a
purposeful life
i think that
living your purpose is where it's so
much about
you and your journey
and living a purposeful life
is when you're now
letting that
overflow into everyone else's life
so it's like you want to find your
purpose and you want to feel satisfied
that in that but a purposeful life
is where you are igniting other people's
purposes and it's overflowing yeah with
that love and that compassion and
gratitude and that's hard because it
takes time and you can't expect people
to do that while they're still filling
up too
and and i think sometimes we you know
everyone will always look like they're
finished and they're done and they made
it
you know it's like
no one's ever made it and you speak to
some of the most successful people in
the world and even they don't feel
they've made it and so
we are always doing both at the same
time you're always filling up your
purpose and you're always trying to be
purposeful at the same time but you're
not
ever going to be fully in purpose and
you're never fully going to be
purposeful it's all a symbiotic
relationship that has to happen in
parallel yeah does that make sense to
your question makes sense to me what i
want you to do is start scheduling time
with yourself in your diary in your
calendar you would never cancel an
important meeting with someone else but
we don't even schedule one with
ourselves if you start by having that
time as your meditation time or you're
not on your phone you're not watching tv
you're not listening to a message or
responding to an email you just sit with
yourself and check in with yourself
and you ask yourself
how am i doing today how do i feel what
do i need to do better
just checking in with yourself is the
beginning of your meditation practice we
live in an age of instant right instant
coffee instant food instant delivery
everything's instant we don't in one
sense even need to adapt and i know
google i've spent a lot of time in
the london offices of google and i'm
sure it's even better here if i'm
allowed to say that
but you know i'm sure that you know
everything's available right you guys
have everything available you don't in
one sense need to adapt you turn up to
work and everything that you need is
right there
and that's the society we live in but
i'm talking about how we need to have an
adaptive attitude i had something happen
to me about a month ago when i was
traveling to la how many of you have
been to l.a how many of you like la
okay popular popular over here yeah so i
love la right i love la so i was going
to la and i love social media as well so
i got my phone out and i sent a tweet
and i said i can't wait to go to la and
i said i really really hope i can get
tickets to the la lakers game tonight
because i'm a big big basketball fan how
many of you basketball fans awesome and
no one here supports the lakers right oh
okay awesome
oh nice okay and i said i really hope i
can get a reservation at my favorite
pizza place because i have a favorite
pizza place in l.a anyone like pizza
yeah easy yeah and so i tagged in my
favorite pizza place i sent a tweet
thought nothing of it i got on the plane
i usually just go to sleep that's my
usual travel routine went to sleep got
off at the other side i grabbed my bags
uh got outside ordered an uber of course
jumped in got off at the other end
was greeted at the hotel by the
concierge went to see the receptionist
and they said to me here you go mr
shetty here's the keys to your room you
know he's the card told me about a bit
of the facilities and then they said you
know what we actually saw your tweet
and because of that we booked you a
reservation at your favorite pizza place
and we've got your tickets to the la
lakers game tonight they're upstairs in
your room
right
now that didn't really happen
but imagine if it did right imagine if
it did i've i've had similar things
happen to me these are all hints and
tips i'm throwing out to the yellow
lakers and uh my favorite pizza place
but imagine if it did now
how many of you be honest how many of
you were with me when i was saying that
how many of you believe me that is true
yeah why did you believe me because it's
possible
because today it's possible
right it's not about who i am i'm not
famous you believe me because it's
possible you believe me because today
brands have to know what's happening in
a customer's life today brands have to
be aware of what people are talking
about on social media you believe me
because it's possible
but actually our experience of life is
very different you can do that for
things but you can't do that for
experiences how many of you have had an
instant powerful experience it's rare
you you can have instant coffee you can
have instant food but to have an instant
powerful experience on demand experience
it's not very easy it takes a lot more
work and that's why adaptive attitude
for our personal lives even if our
technological lives are instant we can't
apply that same thinking and often that
challenges us when we're overcoming
failures that we expect things to happen
quicker because everything else in our
life happens quicker so the adaptive
attitude a great story is about a
gentleman who actually
worked at yahoo i don't know if i'm
allowed to say that
uh worked at yahoo for 12 years i think
he graduated from stanford he had a
great lineup of a great cv had a great
uh career trajectory ahead of him but he
really wanted to go work at facebook and
twitter
right so he applied to facebook and he
got quite far but then he got rejected
so he sent a tweet and the tweet said
really nice people didn't make it in i
hope i can my journey will go better i
hope this can work out he then applied
to twitter got quite far finally got
rejected and sent a tweet saying i'm
glad i got rejected it was a bit of a
long commute right he was seeing the
positive side of things of getting
rejected
a few years on him and his friend from
yahoo they went away and they started
working on apps they thought let's start
a startup let's start working in that
space use of all of our thing we both
you know we've been rejected from this
world let's try go out and do something
together they went out there in four
years they sold their app to facebook
for 19 billion dollars right and that
app is whatsapp now i'm not sure what's
up so popular over here but in the uk
and over in india when i'm traveling
over there everyone's using whatsapp
right and they sold that out for 90
billion that's brian acton the
co-founder of whatsapp that's him
he was rejected from facebook and
twitter and if you go onto google and
type in facebook twitter rejection for
brian acton you'll see the tweets that
he posted they now have millions of
retweets right they're really popular
now but at that time when he sent them
no one even noticed and he reacted
positively online sharing his rejection
with the world
and i look at that and i think wow
that's powerful
how many of us including how many of us
would be able to share a rejection from
a
corporate employer on facebook twitter
online on any of our social media
platforms it's extremely difficult
but his adaptive attitude of actually
looking at the good side of things
looking at the positive
moving away from what the traditional
person would do through a rejection
meant that a few years later he he sold
it and the joke that i've heard in
silicon valley when i've traveled there
is that mark zuckerberg paid 19 billion
dollars for a person he could have hired
for about a hundred thousand dollars
so it's amazing it's it's an amazing
story of having an adaptive attitude
very different to how we do with
technology in our lives but really
powerful of what we can achieve how many
of you have tried to change everything
all at the same time you say to yourself
i want to work on my health i'm going to
improve my career i'm going to get
promoted this year and we're gonna go on
date night every night you start getting
fixated on improving every area of your
life it comes from this desire to be
better and do more but the truth is
you have to choose that one big priority
it has to be not only at the top of the
list in the beginning it has to be the
list there is only one thing you can
improve at a time and you need to choose
wisely it's so easy to get caught up and
think i want to improve my career i also
want to learn more i also want to work
on my relationship i also want to work
on my health
we have to stop that and say this
is my big priority for the next 30 days
make your first step a small step you
may want to be up here but you need to
start down here you need to take the
first step the reason why most people
never get started is that their goal is
so big that they think they have to
achieve that on day one they think that
if they don't get there
they can't start here and this is the
most debilitating frustrating feeling
and that's why we have to simplify and
create that first small step
reading is one of my favorite things to
do but sometimes my stack of books that
i want to read is bigger than the amount
of time i have and at the same time i'm
trying to figure out which one am i
going to get the most value from and
often i'll overthink and procrastinate
i'm sure you can relate so so many
friends will come to me and say my
partner doesn't spend enough time
or i don't have enough time
and what they're really saying is from a
partner point of view is
i really want energy
intimacy and presence and attention it's
attention you're not asking for time
you're asking for attention and i've had
friends who have gone on weekends away
with their partners and they'll come
back and their partner on monday morning
will say i wish we had more time
together and the partners thinking well
but we just spent the whole weekend
together but they're like no because you
were doing your work and by the beach
and you were reading your book and i was
trying to take care of the kids and you
realize it was never time it was
attention it was intimacy it was
presence
and so if we don't define those words
right words are all about definitions if
you don't define them people will break
that contract and that emotional
contract and you have nothing to hold
them to all of us don't have a lot of
time and so one of the reasons we
procrastinate is because we say well i
don't have enough time to figure that
out so i'm just going to put it off i'll
do it next week i'll do it tomorrow i'll
think about it later because we don't
think we have the right amount of time
here's what i've realized and here's a
hack that has helped me break through
that idea i've realized that when i'm
present and focused that's more powerful
than any amount of time when i'm alert
when i'm ready even if i'm there for 15
or 20 minutes i can actually make more
progress than if i had an hour and i
didn't bring my best energy
ask yourself consistently how can you
bring your presence to the task not your
time don't let time be the limiting
factor when i'm having a productive
effective day that doesn't mean i don't
get distracted i get distracted plenty
of times i have tons of notifications
social media big announcements things
that are happening throughout the day
plus a team across the world in
different time zones to manage so when i
get distracted i've created a really
healthy
relationship with distraction i feel
like sometimes our relationship with
distraction is quite negative we see it
as a bad thing we judge ourselves for
feeling distracted we start saying oh i
wish i was more focused or i wish i was
more effective
so i literally got one of these
distraction timers as i call it and i
turn it over as soon as i get distracted
i let the sand run out and as soon as it
runs out i have to get back to my task
this gives me the space and the time to
allow for little distractions and now i
figured out a way to allow myself five
minutes of distraction time every hour
so every hour i allow myself to browse
on my phone for two to five minutes and
that way i know that that time is going
to happen that time is going to come and
that allows me to delay it to put it off
and to postpone my own distractions
one of my favorite ways to deal with
success is continue trying to be
the least successful person
in the room that you and i think there's
those statements of like you know never
be the dumbest person yeah that would be
the smartest person in the room etc and
i think it's the same with
if you become successful
don't just stand at the top of the
mountain don't just stand at the top of
the building
go back down the stairs and and keep
building and keep living as that person
that got you there because you only got
there because you started from the
bottom
right no one starts at the top and so
you started at the bottom and you built
it up and it was that mindset that you
started with that got you there and so
you want to keep rediscovering that
mindset and new parts of it then new
parts of that mindset too
where you're always trying to challenge
yourself and so for me one of the best
ways of dealing with success is keep
expanding the goal posts right keep
widening the goal post keep making them
harder to reach and challenging yourself
because when you challenge yourself
and you push yourself out of your
comfort zone you're naturally humbled
because you're naturally humbled when
you're walking into space i'm sure you
feel this sometimes like sometimes i
walk into a room and i'm like how did i
even get here yeah right like sitting on
a table like i'm the why should i be
here yeah like and and there's part of
it that's impostor syndrome and that can
have its own negativity but part of that
just lets me feel like a beginner again
and i appreciate that feeling and i go
this is amazing because
learning to be grateful
and stop just thinking that oh i earned
all of this and i did it all myself and
i'm self-made you start recognizing
gratitude for all the people that got
you there so for me in success first
thing is be grateful for all your
teachers mentors guides people that got
you there the second thing is always
keep challenging yourself because the
more you're out of your comfort zone the
more naturally you stay humble you don't
stay humble by trying to be humble you
become humbled constantly right by
trying to do stuff that's out of your
league which constantly makes you
prepare
work deepen
all that stuff all of that stuff that
makes you go there again and and then
the third thing you do with success is i
think you try and share it with others
you try and use your platforms as an
opportunity to give other people a
platform yeah so that they can come up
as well because you're reminded of what
a beautiful gift you have because you
made it this far in a video i want to
celebrate you most people start and
don't finish most people never actually
follow through most people say they want
something but they don't ever do the
work to actually get it but you're
different you are special believe nation
you made it here all the way to the end
and i love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to get
some incredible motivation from tony
robbins check the video right there next
to me i think you'll love it continue to
believe and i'll see you there let's
talk about nobody wants to talk about
who here's ever failed
who's here has failed miserably at
something you wanted to achieve say i
who's done this more than once say i